been a thrilled driving the road today
hasn't it you know with all that rain or
snow or slush um today is a day in which
we're setting all the bills that are
oriented around finance and budget and
adequacy not policy inadequate but
primarily the budgeting for uh the
costing of an adequate education and
before we start I want everybody to
understand that we do have a
subcommittee that's already been
appointed to look at these four bills
the paperwork is over on the sides so
everybody could grab a cop if you want
the subcommittee will be meeting
tomorrow at
10:00 and the subcommitte comprises six
people from policy two people from
finance and two people from Ways and
Means and so it's a working group that's
been set up uh between the speaker
myself and and representative Wilhelm
and so it's a bipartisan group there
will be five Republicans five Democrats
on that particular group and we want to
do a really conscientious look at these
four bills and and um hopefully we can
come up with some resolution here um
today I know folks are you know need to
get right on it one of you has to get on
a plane here at by 10:00 so we'll try to
accomplish that so I want to get right
into uh HB
1583 this is relative to per P cost of
anade opportunity for an adequate
education and the prime sponsor that
Bill Wheeler represent wheeler is
represent wheeler here right here Mr
chairman right oh
CH I'm quick you made it exactly yes
okay with the snow thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee uh my name is
representative wheeler I represent the
towns of Peter bro and Sharon uh I I
prime sponsored HB 1583 because right
now how New Hampshire is funding their
schools is
unconstitutional uh the base adequacy
Falls uh significantly short of what the
actual cost of education is um the local
school districts found that that would
be somewhere around $24,000 per pupil uh
in the year 2022 2023 school year uh
right now the base adequacy for our
students is $4,100 per student um that
is significantly under what the school
districts themselves found in the last
school year uh the appropriate base
adequacy would be for our
students based on the work of conval
superintendent Kim believe of sers who
was right behind me here who's my old
superintendent you know it's a little
bit weird to be colleagues now that
we're now that we're here but um uh you
know as I mentioned
she and her work in the conval lawsuit
uh based and came up with uh a $10,000
number basing that off of
um
uh similar metrics that were used before
but not including other metrics that
would be important and um this $9,900
that had been uh formulated based on the
the lawsuit uh didn't include
non-classroom Services which are
necessary to be able to ensure students
can actually access you know instruction
namely transportation
School nurses you know Food Services um
building and Facilities costs and other
things and schools cannot operate with
the base adequacy that it is right now
and I think that everyone on the
committee understands that and that's
why we're we're moving forward with
subcommittees on that level um
superintendent after superintendent
testified that they would not be able to
operate on this current budget and we
need to increase the base adequacy to
invest in our students to invest in
their education and to invest in our
state's future uh if our students are
not invested in then how can they feel
that they're going to stay here how can
they feel uh educated to be able to go
out into the world as uh a full member
of the workforce and and I think it's
clear that $4,100 per student is not uh
an adequate amount to be able to fund
them so hopefully uh My Hope in funding
in filing HB 1583 is that we can find
some mechanism of funding to be able
to
address this situation in a coherent way
everything good up
there okay um so thank you Mr chairman I
I happy to take any questions that the
committee has I'll I'll keep that brief
I have to also get to my own committee
um but I would hope that throughout this
subcommittee process and throughout the
process of the next year we can find in
a bipartisan way some uh adequate way to
fund our our kids in our schools uh here
in New Hampshire thank you very much
representative and just an added note
here um we do have a subcommittee
meeting uh tomorrow on this and again on
the 19th and there we'll be meeting we
have spoken to some of the uh Prime
Movers On on this bill ardinger
representative Ames um others which will
be giving uh more lengthy reports at at
the subcommittee meeting so today what
I'm going to do with a testimony here is
I I I would encourage you not to
replicate what somebody has already said
and there will be a limit of three
minutes not for the person presenting
the bills that person has you know the
latitude to present their bills and try
to um inform all of what that bill
entails but we will have to have a time
limit due to the number of bills which
we have here and the people want to um
speak today so with that are there any
questions of of the representative yes
representa leus and then others
um as I will assume you're
aware we give money in addition to that
minimal amount in lots of other funding
formulas and ways that go in addition
and I'm wondering if the 10,000 that you
came up with takes into consideration
those extra monies that we're already
giving to like towns that have
um lower property values and stuff like
that does that take into consideration
that or is that in addition to that
that'll be an addition to that but also
what I would say representative leus is
that those property poor districts that
what we're talking about here is the
base adequacy amount that they be
receiving so um it would be in addition
to the other money that they're
receiving and making sure that the base
adequacy amount is to an appropriate
amount to be able to fund those schools
okay thank
you representative yes
cordel so it's uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so when
I look at this my first reaction was
like 10,000 such a sort of round number
that it almost seemed arbitrary I'm just
wondering how you came to that
particular figure well as I said in my
testimony I I'm not that smart so I
didn't come up with that figure but um
the people who were in the lawsuit for
the last few months uh Miss Rizzo
Saunders behind me superintendent Rizzo
Saunders and the lawyers and the judge
in that lawsuit has come up with the
number of I think that they had come up
with that number it wasn't it wasn't
made and that number was based off of
the as I said in my testimony the uh
uh it's including the uh her number
$10,000 includes the non-classroom
services that are necessary to be able
to ensure those students Food Services
all those other things that are extra in
school that that's how she came up with
that
$110,000 uh I think the the itself was
75 and that um doesn't include those
non-classroom services so $10,000 that
round number is a bit of a median
between what the uh lawsuit found and
what the court had found and uh the 2400
that the school districts themselves
said would be the base adequacy amount
necessary to fund their schools sort of
10,000 is a little bit of a a middle
ground between there and also what uh
superintendent Rizzo Saunders found uh
in those in her um analysis of what the
school funding would
be further questions represent cordelli
and then represent kin uh thank you
representative wheeler for being here um
I was wondering with this um increase um
in state adequacy um two and a half
times um do you envision um or see the
possibility of Greater State control of
local education than is in place now
with quote unquote local
control
I I I think that would be a different
conversation I don't I mean I think that
for me this is about the the base
adequacy that we're funding to our
schools you know I think of as a student
of conval um and I forgot to mention
this in my testimony but as a student of
conval who conval is a property Rich
District we have a lot of towns we get a
lot of money um and we're very lucky to
have all the opportunities that we have
but 10 minutes down the road in a
neighboring town of Jaffrey uh in the
Conan School District they have a
property poor District that that has
significantly less opportunity so it's
not necessarily about um uh
restructuring the way that we do
education here in New Hampshire it's
about making sure that education the way
that we do it is properly
funded further represent uh K Gaden
thank you Mr chair lad um and thank you
m uh representative wheeler for taking
my question so I'm I'm looking for your
opinion on this um so we know that the
average per pupil expense is between 20
and $24,000 per pupil to educate in a
public school excluding special
education the state constitution says
that the state's responsible for paying
full adequacy and we often see a number
tossed around whether it's four whether
it's three whether it's
10 in your opinion why wouldn't we ask
for full
coverage like it says in the law versus
a number
does the 10,000 get us to where we need
to be for property poor communities do
you know just well I think that we need
to get to full funding eventually
representative cascaden but my opinion
on that would be that the 10,000 gets us
a significant step forward from where we
are and in a in a place where the
schools can finally have the leeway to
be able to start to address some of
those issues that they'd be able to
address with full funding and and once
we get there then it'll be a lot easier
to to move forward from there to get to
the full number and uh the full number
would be uh a a significant undertaking
for the state to take and and I think
10,000 based on uh superintendent
Saunders number is is the appropriate
way to move forward
here
yes oops so in light of this legislation
legislature do you foresee that this
will be an
ongoing movement I mean it's been going
on for years now 20 30
years what makes you think that we'll
get to full funding well representative
cascaden as as long as 20 30 years is
it's uh also not that long you know and
so hopefully um we will you know
we I'm very young you know I'm a I'm a b
I'm a baby here so I I um you know I
think that this fight will continue on I
think the movement will will persist and
um as long as it takes I know that there
are people here in New Hampshire that
will make sure that we have uh Fair
funding for our
schools thank you further
questions not seeing thank you very
thank chairman lad and members of the
committee yeah I'm sure you have do you
have 30 years under your belt no I'm
actually only 20 March 1st March 1st
that's my birthday that's a long
time okay as a courtesy I'd like to have
Kimberly Aris Sanders come up now she's
got to get on a plane here at the
airport in a few
moments welcome thank
you hi so sorry I'm beaming with a
little pride because Jonah is a Condell
grad
so um thank you for allowing me to speak
thank you to Chairman lad for um
allowing me to go first my name is Dr
Kimberly Rizzo Saunders I am the
superintendent of the conell school
districts I want to start by thanking
you for your service I truly appreciate
the work that you do and I do understand
that you answer to many
constituencies and that work is done is
considered and those constituents are
considered in your
decision-making today I'm speaking to
you not only as the superintendent of
conval and on the behalf of the school
board and the nine communities that they
represent I'm also speaking as a
taxpayer myself in hopkington New
Hampshire as Mom and as an educator of
30 years
15 of those years have been in
developing implementing and assessing
School
budgets I'm here obviously to speak to
1583 that proposes to increase adequacy
to $10,000 per
pupil five years
ago representatives of the kbal school
board and myself were here in this very
room in front of this very committee
asking the legislature to increase base
adequacy to $
9,929 per pupil exclusive of
Transportation our request was dismissed
as
excessive and we were for forced to file
a declaratory judgment action in
Superior
Court after receiving a favorable
decision from the Superior Court in
2019 the state appealed to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
the Supreme Court remanded for the
Superior Court to hold a full
trial a trial trial was held this past
April and May 2023 where evidence
established that there's not a single
school in the state of New Hampshire
where an adequate education can be
provided on less than $10,000 per pupil
in many districts it cannot be done for
less than
14,000 per pupil as a matter of fact the
average per pupil expenditure in New
$220,000 the districts proved their case
of trial using four different
methods first I demonstrated using an
input analysis the same methodology used
by this body in the legislature in
2008 that the minimum cost of providing
those compon onon which are required by
state law exceeds $10,000 per
pupil superintendents and business
administrators from 17 other districts
joined me in making that
proof second Dr Bru Baker who was hired
by the state and analyzed the cost of
providing an education whereby there
would be 50% 50%
proficiency
the third for many districts the tuition
to other districts and schools
agreements by the way that are reviewed
and approved by the State Board of
Education is the lowest cost and lower
than if the district provided a bare
minimum based education on their own
finally the state's own expert Dr Robert
castrell had previously determined the
cost of providing a base adequate
education which could be adjusted for
inflation on November 20th 2023 the
Superior Court declared the current
funding system to be
unconstitutional this follows many other
decisions that had the same finding
three minutes
up I would ask if you would consider and
whether or not the committee would vote
to extend my
time I'm sorry I I make that decision
and that's why we have subcommittee
going on tomorrow so so we the the prime
sponsor has a lot of latitude as I
mentioned at the beginning but then it's
3 minutes per person y well I will
submit my written testimony um and I
would urge you to give this the deepest
consideration I will volunteer for any
task force I will I will come and speak
not tomorrow representative lad because
I can't be here as you know because I
will be in DC but I will submit my
written testimony and I will ask repres
restive Luna representative Miler and
representative cascaden to continue to
speak on my behalf thank you thank you
very much and have a safe
sis
okay
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee um I will be with you now and
I'll be coming back shortly to introduce
your next bill as well um but I do thank
you for your time and attention to the
fact that we need to fund people um I am
representative Lauren selig I represent
Durham New Hampshire um I'm also the
proud parent of two Oyster River
students one who is a graduate who has
left the state because um education
opportunities were better for her in
another location um and then my uh
younger one is a junior at Oyster River
High School and um also receive special
education services um but the thing that
I think we need to remember is that
public education is the most critical
service that we can provide absolutely
the most essential we need to ensure
that we fund it fully and properly in
order to support all of our future
doctors our future lawyers our future
state representatives um our future
mechanics our future plumbers our future
electricians whatever services that you
can think of we need to make sure that
these people have a fundamental core
education um Oyster River and I'm not
speaking on behalf of the school system
but Oyster River happens to be one of
the better funded districts in the state
we joined the conval lawsuit because we
also felt it was critical to make sure
that there's adequate funding across the
state um but I can tell you that you
know $3,000 $4,000 doesn't cover much of
anything in a school system anymore the
way the are are extreme and in my
district alone I have constituents who
reach out to me because the property tax
that goes to our local school system is
about 65% of our cost um and people are
not able to get housing because they
can't afford the taxes they might be
able to pay the mortgage but they can't
afford to pay the taxes in order to fund
all of these other things and we need to
restructure our formula so that there is
less of a burden locally and more of a
burden across the state thank you very
much are there any questions of the
representative not see any thanks okay
be back in a little bit uh
you
um I to have so I'm represent Timothy
Horan I'm also represent dur Durham
along with represent celik and I to have
I'm supposed to be in three different
places at one time I mostly came in for
the uh next bill which I am a co-sponsor
of and I would have been happy to been a
co-sponsor of mine and it didn't just
and I just didn't end up on the Mast
head because you know there's a way
things Shuffle around when we do it um
so um one thing about uh one thing about
this bill is um and this is something
that probably has might you want to be
amended is the effective date is July
1st of this year which is pretty soon
the companion bill about special ed they
put that out to uh July 25 so that might
obviate some of the Practical concerns
in the fiscal note which is this cost a
huge amount of money and frankly it's
probably going to have to uh either
involve creating a new tax or increasing
an existing tax which is uh certainly a
NAA to all of us regardless of which
side of the political uh so-called aisle
we're on I mean for some of us that's
pretty much a deal killer for anything
but even for those on my side of the
aisle that's something we hate to do
however this is all going to be offset
by uh reducing local property taxes and
probably the best mechanism although
that's an issue for the next committee
that gets this is a we always have the
Statewide property tax which is not a
great tax but it does exist I mean it
does work it's not fair it's cumbersome
but it does work
um so that's uh and I just want to say
in the past I considered introducing a
bill like this it's I've been around so
long I've been in my ter I've been
around so long that the current governor
was not the governor someone else was a
governor when I started and um actually
I've served under three governors so I
called the budget director who I I she
she I guess I can let her make namess
she's moved on to other things now but I
said like I'm thinking of putting in a
bill that would raise adequacy to a
point which is actually approaches
adequacy and she thought about it for a
minute and laughed and said like um we
don't really know what we think about it
I mean she liked the idea but it seemed
totally impractical but perhaps it is
practical so that which is what this
bill tries to do do so um it um so I uh
I hope you'll do it certainly the
question about State control I certainly
um I certainly in favor of local control
we've passed a lot of bills in the last
few years at Road State Control by
enforcing the con placing limitations on
W can be in the school and I'm against
those but I think giving school
districts more money gives them more
control over uh what they're doing not
less so I would
U urge the committee I know this is
going the subcommittee and U to look at
this bill certain you can tweak the
amounts you can probably tweak the
effective day too so that's up that's I
have to say and also I looks like the
next bill hearing is not going to start
for a while and I have three other plac
that be I'll pass around my written
testimony for uh the next bill and um if
I'm there when pink C just call I'll
I'll speak hopefully more briefly than I
did now because I already made a lot of
points I wanted to make then so thanks
thank you very much there any questions
for the
representative not seeing thank you
thank you uh Sean par I'd like to ask
everybody here that we are speaking uh
we have a number of bills here we one
looking at the component within the the
formula of special education that's
$227,000 we're looking at this on the
base cost at 10,000 let's keep this
discussion to the topic that's in this
bill so we're not going to be discussing
the whole adequacy formula that comes up
on another foundational bill which we
meter
yeah
good morning good morning chairman lad
members of the House Education committee
my name is Michaela Deiter and my
remarks today are made on behalf of the
Dober School Board of which I am an
elected member U just a point of
clarification chairman lad you just
asked for the remarks to be made only to
Bill 1583 I wrote my remarks just in the
interest of time to uh address three
different bills that are being heard
today would you like me to reserve those
for the time when they're being heard
later on in the afternoon well you you
you have to have a pink card on all
those bills if you haven't done that
then you need to speak to this bill um
you also have just three minutes to do
that all within if you'd like to give
some comments regarding all within your
three minute period go for it happy to
do that thank you you're welcome as you
are well aware judge Rua's recent ruling
in the conval lawsuit states that while
it is ultimately up to you as
legislators to determine the cost of
Base adequacy it quote can be no less
than $
7,356 And1 per pupil per year and the
true cost is likely much higher than
that end quote hb1 1583 is proposed
$10,000 base adequacy Aid moves the
needle closer toward fulfilling your
constitutional duty to fund an adequate
public education every New Hampshire
District without exception spends
significantly more than $10,000 per
student the state averages actually
double that at over
$20,000 in Dover we have the ninth
lowest per pupil expenditures in the
state and our homeowners still struggle
to absorb their ever increasing tax
bills the do school board urges you to
move forward with this increase in
adequacy Aid regarding hb1
1656 a 13-fold increase in special
education differentiated Aid might seem
extreme but it is substantiated by New
Hampshire's actual costs in the 2021 22
Academic Year schools spent an average
28,36 in additional funds per special
education student $227,000 in
differentiated Aid is a high number but
it is the real number based on our
state's own data and historical spending
in do like in many other districts we
struggle annually to absorb the
disproportionately increasing special
education costs into our limited budgets
the catastrophic Aid money our district
May partially recoup a year from now
does not improve our Grim Financial
reality as we budget for the upcoming
year which we are doing right now
current levels of special education
funding at just $2,100 per student are
wildly
insufficient finally HB 1686 States what
judge Ruf ruled in November in the Rand
lawsuit retention of excess swept and
Associated negative tax rates is
unconstitutional and must end so much
about school funding is complicated and
nuanced I submit today that in the case
of access swept the decision is
decidedly simple the do school board
urges you to move this bill forward as
proposed so our state can comply with
the outcome of this lawsuit and move
toward Equitable and adequate funding of
all New Hampshire Public Schools thank
you for your time today and for your
service to our state and our schools and
I do have written testimony to sub as
well are there any questions from the
committee yes represent
luno thanks very much and thanks for
joining us this morning thank you Miguel
um could could you tell us a little bit
about how the um the tax cap and over
affects um uh School budgets yeah
absolutely so we've had our tax cap in
place for longer than I've been on the
school board um I think about 10 or 12
years or so um I can give some examples
uh
in in this budget season right now we
were um our tax cap allowable amount
which compared to other years was quite
generous because we have had a an
economic boom uh our tax cap is based on
the consumer price index average of the
past three years so we had a pretty
significant increase it amounted to
about um 3,000 or $3,200,000 I believe
for this year to to put that into
perspective our school budget is about
$85 is million doll give or take um
depending on what you count in that
group the um the tax cap is a burden
every single year um it was only not a
burden the first year of covid because
we had to significantly cut back on very
expensive things like transportation for
the year so we were able to come in
under the tax cap at that point it is a
an annual struggle every single year
last year we did manage to um to come in
under the tax cap but it came at a
significant price to our district um the
year before that we had a $3.6 million
override and again that's within the
context of an $85 million School budget
so it was a pretty significant override
um that was to to keep the lights on so
to speak uh we're you know we're not
installing Olympic siiz swimming pools
and sending our our students to Italy um
that was basic operational costs this
year to um to keep our budget within the
tax cap we would have to cut 27 teaching
positions as a reference and to be clear
that is not on the table currently um as
we say so so often in our school board
meetings um it is not on the table to
cut 27 teaching positions that's the
equivalent of one entire grade which of
course will never happen but we
encountered about $2.2 million in excess
special education costs within the past
three or four months only due to new
students coming into the district
students having um uh IEPs that didn't
exist before or needing to be sent out
of District um and and transportation
for special Aid was a huge factor in
that so as I said before we had about
$3.2 million in increase that would be
within our tax cap um $2.2 million of
that uh was automatically used up by our
federally mandated rights for our
special education students to provide
them an adequate education um
additionally we had about $2.5 million
in reduction from State um state income
so it has it has been dire to to put it
mildly um it is difficult it is very
difficult to balance the needs of our
taxpayers with the needs of our students
and what is uh federally required of us
to provide an adequate education to our
special education students it is never
easy and and every year it never gets
easier we are significantly hampered by
our tax
cap thank you for your question thank
you further questions from the committee
not see thank you very much would you
like me to hand in my testimony oh yes
absolutely yes will become part of the
record here no no right at the end right
um Sorry Miss okay I was just about
ready to call I'll call you after this
okay this one right here all right um
SAU 32 and
100 uh
Sydney you know I really know why we
passed legislation last year dealing
with cursive
writing
and I've see that on a lot of
cards so
welcome thank you very
much uh thank you for um hearing me this
morning I'm actually kind of happy about
the timing of me being called up right
after do because I'm here to speak
hopefully on behalf of small rural
districts in New Hampshire so that I can
offer you a little bit of a different
perspective on uh the effect that uh
adequacy especially this base adequacy
number has on some small rural districts
currently so I am the superintendent of
the planfield and Cornish school
districts they are two school districts
but like many other staff they uh share
a
superintendent I'm asking this committee
to consider this $10,000 change and to
fulfill a step towards fulfilling the
Constitutional obligation uh to fund an
adequate education for all of New
Hampshire
students as we are going into budget
season uh we have our budgets in draft
form at this point getting ready for our
public hearings as I'm sure most
districts do and I wanted to give you
some actual numbers of what the tax
burden is on local taxpayers so for
example if you are looking at the
Cornish School District the budget
increase of approximately
4.8% which in this day and age of
inflation is looking pretty good and
reasonable will transl into an
approximate
88.9% increase on local tax dollars if
you're looking at the plane field draft
budget at this point a
1.75% increase which is what we are
proposing will translate into an
11.7% increase on local taxpayers what's
happening because of property values
because of this formula in small rural
districts is an extreme burden burden on
local
taxpayers we are looking at basic needs
no budget has anything frivolous or
fancy in it at this point we are trying
to do what we can for academic
achievement and learning
recovery on top of those issues oh I I
should also mention the 1.75% increase
does not include any collective
bargaining agreements that is just
operating expenses that will translate
into an 11.7%
increase um in addition to academic
achievement we're also looking at
learning recovery over the last couple
of years which takes additional
resources in terms of building uh needs
one of the communities is also looking
at issues with pasas a major roof repair
not even maybe repair reconstruction
HVAC issues and asbestos only three out
of 17 building a projects were funded so
we believe that this is also a burden
that will fall on local
taxpayers both of these districts work
diligently to share wherever they can to
reduce these burdens on local taxpayers
we share staff uh we have one school
that makes lunch in the kitchen and
drives it to the other District to the
other school to deliver it uh we're
thinking of ways we can even share a
tractor we share staff we are also
considering ways that we can share
students and all of those things are
good conversations to have however this
is all um part of the effort an
extraordinary effort that goes into
funding what we believe can be an
adequate education for our
students I want to end for the small
rural District by saying um in small
ponds ripples are
bigger so when you're looking at this
adequacy amount um when you're looking
at the effect it could have on a do I
also want you to consider the effect
that it has on these small districts
where these tax increases for local
taxpayers are huge one final comment is
given the formula um for the Cornish
district for example uh with the
reduction or elimination of
stabilization Aid um after next year if
the formula continues the Cornish school
district will see an $80,000 decrease in
adequacy every year if student
population stays the same because of the
reduction in hold harness thank you very
much time are there any questions are
there any questions from the committee
laus I'm totally not understanding your
math so if you can explain to me please
um how a small increase in your what
it's going to cost leads to such a large
percentage increase leads to such a
large percentage increase in the tax
rate because of revenues because when
you have expenses on one side if you
don't have revenues that match if your
revenues are lower your expense increase
percentage goes up okay thank you sure
thank you further
questions thank you again thank you for
par welcome good morning thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Sean par
and I'm on the Manchester School Board
where I chair the education legislation
committee today I'm speaking on behalf
of the Manchester School Board which has
authorized me to advocate for fully
funding education in New Hampshire we
urge you to approve HB
1583 and uh as you know Manchester is
one of the plaintiffs on the conval
lawsuit and so we I will summarize this
uh we also agree that uh with the trial
court ruling in favor of the plaintiffs
it's time to change the way we do
adequate education in New Hampshire uh
we would like to know how you the state
legislature plan to act on this ruling
to give some perspective on the gravity
of the need for increased funding I
think it's important to understand how
underfunded the city of Manchester has
been using data from the New Hampshire
Department of Ed which appears to be
maybe a little bit behind what I heard
for the average amount there the cost
per pupil the average cost if we say is
around $20,000 per student uh Manchester
as New Hampshire's most populace most
diverse and most impoverished student
body we're at the very bottom of how
much we spend per student at $155,000
per student uh with over 12,000 students
we would need more than $50 million per
year in order to raise our spending up
to the average New Hampshire level this
is the definition of chronic
underfunding we are grateful for the
Boost of funding granted during the last
budget cycle it will do wonders for our
students but it doesn't get the state to
where it needs to be to have a fully
funded
system with this first step that the
state took in the last budget cycle and
the the conal ruling which has
substantiated the dire need to increase
Aid and change the adequacy formula it's
time to take those next steps revise the
formula and fully fund New Hampshire
schools we need to increase funding
particularly to those districts with the
greatest need that's another reason why
I'm here to reiterate the fact that
Manchester is such a district with over
50% of our students qualifying for free
and reduced lunch uh and with around 25%
of our students qualifying for special
education
services that's why we also support the
next two bills on your docket HB 1656
which increases aid for students
receiving special education services and
HB
1586 which uh re-envisions how we fund
education in this state to become a
system of public school funding that
allocates funding from the state sources
to those communities with the greatest
need and lowest capacities in order to
ensure that the state provides all
children with an opportunity for a
constitutionally adequate education
regardless of where they live fly
funding education in New Hampshire is
desperately needed thank you for your
consideration thank you any questions
from Manchester yes represent luno thank
you thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much um uh chair par for for
being with us this morning could you
talk a little bit about some of the
challenges that are unique that that
that you face uniquely in
Manchester sure uh I mean I'm not sure
where to start but I think uh generally
speaking you know I heard from the other
school board representative some of
those same issues are also apply to
Manchester particularly the special
education services which have
skyrocketed in past years uh but also
Transportation which has really
increased in cost over the last several
years there you know we you know I think
we are in dire need there but you know
we're not without hope in Manchester we
have a good superintendent we're very uh
hopeful that uh we will be able to start
turning some things around we have an
outline of a plan for long-term
facilities updates we have an outline uh
we have uh gone through a very
successful negotiation with our unions
there so we have some reason to believe
that there's some hope for getting at
for improvement in Manchester that said
you know every year we are still kind of
tying things together so to speak to
make sure that we provide the best
education we can for our students there
um I think that uh what we've been
trying to do is to find ways to advocate
for our eles right here at the state
level there but also to find ways to
make do with less and I think that that
making do with less has been our Mana
for quite some time for quite some time
thank you further yes go ahead so thank
you again Mr chair and thank you thank
you for uh for taking the follow-up
question could um could could you also
um uh uh
indicate how many students are in the
Manchester School District compared
compared to across our um great state of
New Hampshire and um um yeah ju just
really that sure so we have 12,300
students in our district uh by the last
count that I saw there um so that you
know it's 21 schools uh it's a very
large system we have uh uh we're really
one of the largest employers in the
state in that way it's a very large
system and so uh one of the things we've
been trying to do is to make that system
a better system and when you investigate
systems as large as Manchester you see
so many areas where the supports have
been kind of glued together to make ends
meet and so we are seeing more and more
how in order to make our systems right
and fair and Equitable for our students
we need to change how the system works
in a certain way and a lot of that has
to do with funding uh but it also has to
do with organization and we've done a
lot already with the way we've organized
our district there and I think you know
if we're talking 12,300 students there
that's you know that's a good proportion
there of of of of resources there and I
you know I I have been to all 21 schools
I have seen the state of our buildings I
have seen uh how much our teachers have
to do for our students there how we have
to how we have to really work hard to
reduce class sizes in places where
there's a squeeze and I think you know
Personnel can only do so much right we
have great person but you know they've
been working really hard and at the at
their end for quite some time there so I
think that this type of increase in
funding is really urgently needed in
order to support our students our
teachers and and the people of New
Hampshire because it has a far-reaching
effect for the future thank you thank
you very much uh further questions from
the committee thank you thank you for
gy
welcome thank you I drove through your
town today no doubt you uh saw the
rocket the missile yes I did right there
in Warren uh my name is Michael gy I'm
in my fifth year as principal of a
Warren Village School a small rural
remote prek through 8 institution uh W
wvs is a school with proud wooden bones
that date back to the
1850s what struck me in judge Rua's 56
page ruling that found the state's
adequacy Aid unconstitutional is the use
of the word conservative does anyone
here know how many times the judge used
the word conservative in his decision
document 45 times he used it not only
when setting his own mind monetary
calculus to the cost drivers of
education but to the numbers the
plaintiffs used in making their case in
other words he reasoned that the
plaintiff's use of conservative numbers
when reaching a constitutional adequacy
Aid of
$99,900 was fair yet he decided to one
up them and ruled for an adequacy aid
that is
$2,543 199
less he doesn't leave us guessing
he did that quote because he said he
undervalued the requisite level of
funding and deference to the legislature
I think he was talking about you I think
like me he reasoned that among one of
the world's largest legislative bodies
there would have to be great minds that
will figure this out and will do the
just and honorable thing for our
proy let me share another concern
conservative education number with you
37.5 that is the contract hours per week
that my district demands from our
teachers that is the calculus used for
their salary my district is a school
that has a student population identified
by the doe as having a higher
economically disadvantaged rate than
93% of all other schools in New
Hampshire we are educating students with
no running water and I know you get it I
know I don't need to fold in the numbers
of students who are being raised by
single parent households or
grandparents or the number of students
who have not just experienced trauma but
are living in dramaa believe it or not I
can tell you how many students my
teachers are feeding out of their own
Pockets I can tell you how many pairs of
shoes my teacher have bought their
students so far this year and how many
coats we issue every recess and let it
be known that these noble men and women
labor at a lower average salary than
80% of all other teachers in New
Hampshire you know what these stats howl
failure and yet in the newly released
data by the doe Warren Village School
has a higher score in math than
88% of all other schools in the state
our combined math and Ela scores placed
us at a ranking of 124th out of 453
schools do you think that our teachers
are doing that at a conservative 37
hours your time is expired so wrap it up
please I will wrap it
up um the days when great principles
like Ray Burton one of my esteemed
predecessors at Warren Village School
Could Walk The Halls slapping a wooden
paddle and making all right with the
world are gone raised kids are not my
kids we need help help I think deep down
all of you on both sides of the aisle
know it and I ask you on behalf of my
students their caregivers my staff
please honor the state constitution by
finishing the work that judge ruof
respectfully deferred to you and bless
you all any questions yes represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and and
thank you very much um uh principal gy
for uh for joining us this morning
pleasure um I was wondering if you could
um um well you know just prior to you we
had chairman par from Manchester say how
there was a
12,300 students in the Manchester School
District how many how many kiddos do you
have in the Warren well we started out
with 70 this year and we're down to 64
we have probably about five families or
five students each year it's a
transitory population it jumps it it it
declines uh we're projecting 60 at this
point for next year um but then it it it
changes but a very low number uh most of
our classes are combined for that very
reason okay a quick follow up Mr chair
so would it would would you agree then
that um or would it be fair to say that
that New Hampshire's school funding
formula isn't working for both large
districts like Manchester or small
districts like
Warren I can't speak to the larger
districts I know that our average per
pupil rate is
$26,000 I know that up the street rumney
is
$37,000 I know that the larger schools
it may be 20,000 I can say the speaker
earlier that said in small rural
districts the ripple effect is more
profound I can absolutely testify to
that uh we're struggling and as you know
it's hard to recruit young teachers
they're not going to work 60 hours a
week that's what my teachers are doing
uh surrounded by uh taxpayers that are
mad as Hades great thank thank you very
thank you very much any further
questions representative r thank you can
you just give us your school budget
number please um so uh it's increasing
as you know but I think it's
approaching uh about
2,800,000 y further questions Michael's
from SAU
23 I had a grandson who went to
kindergarten in a school thank you very
Neil
good
morning thank you Mr chairman um my name
is Casey Neil I am with the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project and I am going to be reading um
some testimony that has been submitted
on behalf of the Pittsfield middle high
schools Fair funding Learning
Studio to the house education committee
on behalf of students from the
Pittsfield school district and students
whose education is handcuffed across the
state we are urging your support of the
proposed bills that would increase
funding and support for schools in our
state in Pittsfield a small property
poor town just half an hour from our
Capital students have lived through the
inadequate funding formula every day we
have had our schools budget SL some
years resulting in losing valuable
courses that provoke thought and prepare
us for the real world we don't have the
money in our school budget for foreign
language teachers which most colleges
and universities require two years of
just to submit an admissions
application we don't have a music
teacher as our district cannot compete
with larger school districts who can
offer candidates much higher pay we need
more support staff to assist our special
education students who require support
to help ensure their academic and
personal growth we have so many needs
yet so little money to meet those needs
our taxpayers have to draw a line
somewhere and cost of living has already
increased so much over the years forcing
the hand of Pittsfield residents to vote
down important measures for our school
for too long the state has not fulfilled
its promises made in the initial
Claremont lawsuit before we were even
born it is time to make right on the
promises made to our future generations
for an adequate education our education
should not be defined by the zip code in
which we live as students we are held to
basic expectations such as completing
assignments on time yet the promises
once made by our Supreme Court have
missed its deadline by over 20 years we
now have the opportunity to correct this
mistake and provide a more adequate and
equ a education to all of our students
across the state please support bills
that will help our schools and future
Generations sign the students of
Pittsfield Middle High School's Fair
funding Learning Studio and I've got
copies for the committee thank you very
much um and I also just wanted to
mention that Karen uh Hill who was
called earlier has uh joined us okay
thank you any questions from the
committee no go ahead thank you very
correct am I right is you got it do
right exactly right Mr chairman and
thank you for this opportunity um uh I
I'm going to try and come at this a
little bit differently um my name is
Thomas Opel I am here representing
myself uh but I'm uh I'm from Kanan the
Hampshire um also a small rural Town not
quite as small as Warren or planfield or
carnish but uh but small enough um I
chair our Economic Development Committee
um because we're trying to relieve some
of the burden on our on our homeowners
on our property taxpayers in our
community and they are struggling about
a third of the families in canyan live
below the poverty line so we have a very
diverse population but we have some
families that are having a very very
hard time and I I kind of want to make
two
points the first point is that our
public schools from the founding of this
nation it's not just in our constitution
but just about every single one of the
founders of this nation talked about the
importance of public education public
education as a unifier as a place where
we T teach people how to be citizens in
a democracy in a republic um a fact
recognized by this legislature when you
passed legislation requiring better
Civics
education um and public schools are also
a place where we bring people together
in ways that don't happen as much
anymore in this country um it is the
great unifier in many ways people come
together and experience themselves um
and meet people of of different
backgrounds different economic
backgrounds so they're critically
important to our democracy and working
together they're also important from an
economic
standpoint uh the fact of the matter is
they're creating the workforce of the
future and in New Hampshire when we talk
about the New Hampshire Advantage we've
kind of gained the system the fact of
the matter is we're the second oldest we
have the second oldest population in the
country and uh 60% of our population was
not born here I I'm one of those people
I I as the saying goes I wasn't born in
New Hampshire but I got here as soon as
I could um I uh my first job out of
college was teaching at a public school
in Hudson New Hampshire um I think about
15 years before the first Claremont
decision the first Claremont decision
think about that 1976 when I started
teaching 1993 was the first Claremont
decision that told us what we were doing
the way we were funding Public Schools
was
unconstitutional um I will say as
someone who has three children who have
now all finished high school although
one is still a UNH um the the the fact
of the matter is we we have been doing
this a long long time we've recognized
the problem courts have recognized the
problem it is hurting us uh we can't
continue to have an elderly population
just getting more and more elderly as
our young folks leave the state for
better opportunities um in Canan we
spend uh about uh $23,000 per pupil and
as any business person knows scale is
critically important there are certain
fundamentals that you have to pay for
whether you have 10 students or 12,000
students um you know buildings cost
money to build to equip to heat to
maintain um and those are fixed costs
that you know um as I say the the
student
population impacts it to some degree but
at at some base level you're going to
have to pay for that and that has an
impact both on your
community the other thing that public
schools represent in many ways are
Community Pride whether it's academics
or Athletics um you know these are these
are sources of Community Pride and
they're critically important to our
Economic Development and our democracy
um and if I can just make one last Quick
point one of the things that is
happening in Kanan and I know it's
happening in a lot of other communities
particularly those like Kanan that are
struggling you're creating a situation
in which property taxpayers who are
already struggling are beginning to
resent the money they spend on public
education because those tax rates
typically are the biggest rate on their
on their tax bills that's a dangerous
path to go down to start having people
resent public
education um I and I hope this committee
takes this first step um
$10,000 is a good first step
but it's not enough thank you very much
any questions from the
committee wait until those grandkids
come along you're gonna have to pay for
them
too as long as they're still in the
turny good morning good morning thank
you chairman lad thank you members of
the committee um I'm speaking here in
support of this bill and I'd actually
like to address some questions that were
asked of the uh SP or earlier um we're
here to talk about base adequacy base
adequacy is the cost to educate a child
okay that does not qualify for any of
the differential AIDS because of that
particular child's learning needs in
other words base adequacy is the least
expensive hypothetical minimum for the
least expensive to educate child
assuming that all other state funding
sources whether that be for special
education or whether that be for uh
building Aid are fully funded okay that
analysis of base adequacy is what Dr
Rizzo Saunders determined in
2019 okay cost
9,929 per pupil that's what Dr Baker
determined in 2020 as part of the
legislative study commission Dr Baker's
analysis was paid for by the Legislative
study commission and he determined that
it was
$996 in 2020 here we are in 2023 talking
about the costs of
2024 um and those costs have gone up
there's something called inflation um
you know if I was representative wheeler
I wouldn't have set that number at
10,000 it would have been higher than
10,000 um but there is a cost there is a
real cost I ask each and every one of
you to think about what that real cost
is think about it in your communities
think about it Statewide okay there's
also something that has been alluded to
um which is districts with transitory um
student populations have additional
costs okay judge Rua's decision was
presuming the most conservative number
in a perfect real world in which every
single classroom had exactly 30 students
that's not really possible okay because
you can't say we are the whatever school
district and once we reach 30 students
we're not going to allow any more first
graders in we're not going to allow any
more second graders in we've reached our
30 students no once another student
comes in the school district needs to
educate that child they need to hire a
teacher maybe Midway through the year
which is really really difficult and
really really expensive which is why um
you you don't have perfect efficiency in
any school district in the state so if
there's any questions for me I'd be
happy to answer any questions but I want
the uh committee to think about that
this $10,000 bill is presuming that all
of the differential Aid is fully funded
it is not including any building Aid or
any other state uh funding sources or
any federal funding sources this is
determining the lowest possible
cost thank you very much and representa
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here could you indicate where
you are from yes and also the second
question is since you since you
obviously are aware of the case uh can
you under can you Enlighten the
committee on what the state said their
defense was for their
$4,100 and what what the basis of their
findings were as far as how that $4,100
came about yes thank you representative
Myer um I live in the town of hopkington
um I also served as lead councel in the
conal case um the state did not have a
defense that the $4,100 is actually the
true cost of providing an adequate
education the state only attacked the
plaintiff's arguments um arguments which
the court found to be fully credible but
the $4,100 does not have any um relation
to what the true cost of providing an
adequate education is to the least cost
to educate child followup please yes so
Mr attorney what you're saying is that
the state then had no basis for how they
came up with the $4,100 is that correct
correct in fact um the state had no
basis thank you further questions from
the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much thank you uh Natalie
yeah glad you could read my hand writing
Mr chairman that was easy to read oh
good thank you yeah you must have had
curse of uh the Palmer method or the xer
blowser method or one of them sure yes
thank you all right thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee I
am a resident of bosin but a native of
Berlin and a proud graduate of Berlin
Public Schools where I guess I learned
my cursive very well so thank
you I'm an attorney on uh the Rand
lawsuit which is the other school
funding lawsuit besides conal that's
currently happening um but I'm
testifying on behalf of myself I do
support the increase to base adequacy
but House Bill 1583 Falls fall far short
of the actual cost so as you've heard
the court in conal issued an order on
November 20th setting a baseline of
about
$7,300 as the minimum threshold for what
the state should fund base adequacy
importantly that was the only issue
before the court in conal base adequacy
not looking at any differentiated Aid as
Mr Tierney just explained but also um
there's a different approach in conval
of how they proved their case about
adequacy our case Rand is still ongoing
and we challenge both base adequacy and
differentiated Aid and even within base
adequate adequacy itself we have a
broader approach to tackling how much it
actually cost and we assert that the
actual cost of AD adequacy should be
close to the average spending in the
state and based on the doe data and this
is based on the um adma as of 12 22 23
so very recent the average cost per
people for 2022 2023 was over
$20,000 and when you add in other
expenditures like Transportation
construction and interest the average is
actually over
$24,000 so even with differentiated Aid
included and other funding um setting
base adequacy at 10,000 as this bill
does will not reach the level of actual
spending and the actual cost of
inadequate education that the state is
constitutionally obligated to provide
thank you thank you very much other
Trumble thank you Mr chairman David
written testimony is there place I
should
yeah good morning committee members my
name is David Trumble from the town
aware there's been a lot of testimony so
I will not try to repeat things but I do
want to go over a few points first I
think it's important to go back to the
original Claremont decision that
decision had four major Holdings first
it's the state's duty to provide an
education all the children in New
Hampshire not the town's Duty second is
that the level of Education must be
constitutionally adequate third is the
state must guarantee adequate funding
and fourth is that this Duty applies to
the public schools that word is taken
directly from the Constitution this does
not apply to private schools as for the
ruof decision I hope that every member
of this committee has read that decision
I've gone through it a couple times
myself if you have not before you vote
on any of these bills I urge you to read
it through from cover to cover that
judge does conservatively pick the
$7,300 number but he says 9900 is more
likely to be the base number that's
constitutionally minimum he also says
that's an inputs based analysis he looks
at Dr Baker's analysis who was
originally hired by you and he came up
with about the same figure using an
output space analysis but judge R said
I'm not going to consider that because
this case is based on how to what's the
inputs but it's interesting as a
benchmark he said that either system you
come up with that's the bare minimum
number this decision has fundamental
importance to our state because 85% of
our children go through the public
schools that means 85% of the people who
vote for you in elections go went to a
public school 85% of the people who work
in this state or moms and dads in the
state go through Public Schools this is
essential not only to them as
individuals but to our economy as was
mentioned previously it's also essential
to our informed citizenry in the very
functioning of our democracy the problem
with funding in the state is specific
particularly hard for places that don't
have enough property tax base to
adequately fund their own schools the
state contribution is grossly inadequate
small towns big towns that have lots of
low-income students places without
without a strong property tax base those
communities cannot adequately fund their
education we're talking tens and tens
and tens of thousands of children and
their schools every day have to choose
between fixing the roof or having a
reading instructor or having classrooms
that have 30 or 35 children in the
classroom if any of you have been
Educators and I imagine a lot of you
have been being on this committee you
know how hard that would be the choices
that are being made in the state every
day are being put on the backs of our
children this is your obligation it's
been your obligation for almost four
decades it's time that the legislature
live up to its obligation and stop
looking at school funding as an expense
but looking at it as an investment in
our future if you consider it an
investment you will be proud to at least
put $10,000 per per child thank you for
your time thank you very much David are
there any questions yes represent
luno thank you very much Mr Shar and
thank you very much Mr Trumble for uh
for being here uh this morning and for
taking my question um it's it's somewhat
of a technical question um and and I
hope you can you can you know help uh
help us with this but you introduced the
idea of an input-based analysis compared
to an outcomes based analysis such as
what Dr Baker um did and while the while
the the base numbers for that came out
pretty pretty close I was wondering what
if you can talk to us about what the
difference is between an input-based
costing analysis and an outcomes based
costing analysis so input based would be
what does it cost us to provide the
buildings the classrooms the the uh the
number of teachers based on the class
size so it's just based on what do we
have to do in order to physically run a
school and that's at least 10,000 at a
bare minimum we know it's more than that
an output space system just says let's
forget about what the what the inputs
are what's our goal we want to have an
educated citizenry what does it cost us
to do that and then you work backwards
and I know that you're uh Bill coming up
a couple down the road here the work of
the commission the 2020 commission that
you and chairman lad were on used an
outputs based formula and you said what
do we need in order to adequately fund
our schools if we look for the results
rather than the inputs and that number
Dr Baker says is about the same so
basically either way at a bare minimum
you need
$110,000 so I I won't get into
testifying on the third bill I'll I'll
speak to that one later but I think
that's just basically it's interesting
that either way you look at it you come
to about the same
amount I I I I want to be cautious how
far we dig down now we're going to be
doing a lot of this tomorrow you and I
have gone through tputs inputs versus
output performance and all that Doe 25
forms and all that um and I think
David's right in giving that brief
definition and I think that's where we
all stop it for this yes thank you um
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman you're welcome Karen Hill is
yes thank you Mr chairman you're welcome
members of the committee my name is
Karen Leo Hill I am a 19-year city
councelor in the city of Lebanon the
former mayor I'm also the Grafton County
Treasurer but today I'm here as an
individual because our city council um
has not had a chance to review this
legislation in
particular it is frustrating that 30
years after the first Claremont lawsuit
we are still here without a resolution
we've known for a long time that the
state's allotment currently around
$4,000 is insufficient to fully fund an
adequate
education and we've also known that the
disparities that result from Big
differences in fund available at the
local level have also persisted for
these past 30
years and there was more than sufficient
evidence to Prevail in the conval
lawsuit as has been discussed
$110,000 is a conservative figure for
the true cost of an adequate
education New Hampshire children deserve
the chance to succeed and to live up to
their full
potential the child zip code should not
determine their educational
opportunities funding education is also
an economic issue and I do want to
underscore the testimony of Thomas Opel
which I found very compelling from the
economic development perspective it is
past time for the legislature to address
education funding in New Hampshire I
urge the committee to send this to to do
the work uh that you have discussed and
to ultimately send this to the floor
with a recommendation of a to pass thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee have a good drive back to
Lebanon
Heber okay you're
Coral this one is good morning Kor I
live just six miles up the road in
Penacook um I was a public School
educator for 14 years and my stud my
children went through Public Schools as
did I in New Hampshire um I want to
thank you for the the Forward Thinking
about the interconnectedness of policy
structure and finance because this isn't
you can't just throw money um at a
problem I think our public schools are
amazing and I support them that's the
hill all die on and they aren't perfect
and our structures aren't perfect and I
so I think we definitely need to
consider the interconnectedness of all
of those things um I hope that you will
um think about uh including students in
the conversations that you'll be having
in the subcommittees um including places
like um pitsfield but also I encourage
you to think about other places like
Franklin um which does have a tax cap um
and also funds their education
interestingly compared to the rest of
the state um I wanted to just reiterate
um that I hope that this is the year um
that we finally get this done and that
legislators uphold their Oaths to the
constit tion and at the very least
provide a significant increase to the
state's contribution to public education
especially for our poorest districts
which not incidentally have the highest
rates of 504s and
IEPs I've personally never liked that we
use the word adequate to describe
education it's too subjective it's
uninspired um and because we failed to
Define it in a way that accounts for our
changing economy and technological
advancements it's been quite easy for
leaders to lowball the actual cost and
contribution reminder when uh Claremont
happened we didn't have all this
technology and so that is an extra
burden an extra cost that we've had over
the course of the years that I don't
think we've accounted for in our funding
um I would like to consider a quality
education where each child regardless of
zip code and socioeconomic status of
their parents and Community has the same
access to Dynamic and rigorous learning
experiences as their peers the next town
over Universal quality might be too much
to ask for so I'll ask for adequacy in
the words of coach belich do your job
ensure our public schools have the money
to provide the best education for each
student education that affects the
quality of life for all of us thank you
thank you very much Tom Brady did do his
job too yes I'm expecting that you all
will as well thank you very
much um I saw you walk in Bill Bill
aringer are you wanting to speak on this
one or 15 156 1586 okay and the last
morning Zach
speaker um do we have any more on
this
M all right well I'll jump in while
you're looking for that that's all right
so I'm Zack Shen I'm here representing
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project uh for those of you who
don't know us we are a nonprofit
organization that does education around
school funding and property taxes in the
state um tries to engage um citizens
school board members students and really
try to Advocate um for both our students
and taxpayers for a fairer system um I
will do my best to not repeat uh things
that have been said previously in the in
the interest of time do want to
highlight a number of things and I can
pass on my uh testimony after
uh just to reiterate something that's
been brought up a few times I want to
kind of really drive home this point the
current amount of school funding that
the state contributes to schools
including differential Aid which is a
little outside the scope of the current
bill is still only a little over $5,000
per student compare that to the average
expenditures of $220,000 depending on
what you include is a huge mismatch
between how much the state is supplying
to schools and how much is born on the
backs of local property taxpayers
uh some the rate current uh rates range
property tax rates um from a121 in
millsfield to $15 79 cents in Hinsdale
those are just for districts actually
have students it's much lower for some
places that don't have students
themselves um and the Crux of this is a
continual downshifting of this
responsibility to fund our public
education to local property taxpayers
it's about $2 billion a year that we are
currently raising from local local
property taxes to pay for our Public
Schools we pay for 70% of all of our
Public Schools all the revenue for them
from local property tax paays uh
multiple people have quoted the Supreme
uh Superior Court rulings from Judge
ruof about how the base accuracy number
he arrived at the 7300 is a very
conservative number um but just to kind
of put that in reference and answer our
question from earlier that is not
advocating for an increase in overall
public education funding this current
bill and the ruling from the conval
lawsuit could represent a shifting in
responsibility from local property
taxpayers to where it belongs to at the
state just to give you a ballpark figure
if this bill were to go into effect and
school districts were to pass those
savings directly on to local property
taxpayers to keep the same amount of
money we're currently spending we
decrease the burden from about 70% to
only 45% funded by local property
taxpayers for public school
systems I also want to address this kind
of back and forth the courts legislature
can't have it both ways you can't ignore
Court ruling standing Supreme Court
precedent for years and then the fact
that we happen to have some ongoing
lawsuits right now want to just wait and
see where they lead before taking action
addressing that specific concern one of
the things has not been brought up that
came out of the conv Val ruling from the
from the court quote it is likewise
cognizant that school funding is a
complicated and politically charged
issue with a history that suggests some
level of judicial intervention is now
necessary among other things though the
legislature hired expert witness to
analyze school funding issues and
provide an informed recommendation base
Advocate is currently funded at less
than half of his recommended level this
is just one example that calls into
question whether the politics of this
issue are impeding the state's
constitutional obligation to fully fund
the opportunity for children in the
state to receive an adequate education
that ends today was that my time all
right I'll jump to the end so thank you
I appreciate you uh taking the time to
listen to My Testimony I just want to
highlight that what is missing is not a
lack of data of information of judicial
rulings you have the vehicles before you
to move forward on this there are a
number of bills be hearing from later
and I'll also hand out my testimony
along with um testimony from 130 folks
who couldn't be here today but wanted to
submit um their support for this Bill
thank you very much are there any
questions Mr shahen thank you very
much Donna we found your
card it said 1584
had the wrong number on the card I felt
like I was in the restaurant everybody
me welcome thank you thank you you you
get
dessert that's good so thank you for
allowing me to speak today um I just
want before I say who I am as you know
I'm Donna mum but I just want to I want
to just put you in a position so I want
you to put you in a position as an
educator you're in your classroom and in
comes your first student who last
evening their father was arrested for
dealing
drugs I also want you to picture the
next child coming in who
was unfortunately molested by a
sibling the next child coming in lives
with their grandparent because their
house that they lived in was considered
um where drugs were um
housed the next the next child that
comes in has not eaten since Friday when
they came to
school I'd like to say to you my name is
Donna magon welcome to
Newport not all of our students have
that but I will share with you that a
large majority of our
students suffer from one of those
things I
report at least 10 to 15 DCF cases a
week if not within 2 to three
days our teachers and our staff our
parents social workers nurses protectors
holder of information whether it's good
information or bad information but
they're also mandatory mandatory
37,39 that is between $6,000 to
$10,000 different from our surrounding
towns I have 81 teachers of those 81
teachers 28 of them are on an
alternative plan which means they never
went through the education
process the the staff turnover and our
district can be at times have been 25
teachers that we've had to
replace I currently have 200 staff
members I am missing seven teachers and
roughly 18
staff we are now in our budget season
and our budget is is approximately uh 22
million
and two days ago I was asked to cut
$848,000
from that budget because of the tax
impact it will have on our
community the 2223 school year the cost
22,27 the tax impact on our community is
causing a number of our families to lose
their homes so as I sit here today I ask
all of you to please support this bill
support our students support our
Educators and support our families thank
you thank you very much Donna um are
there any questions from the committee
thank you very much for making the trip
to Newport thank you so much you're
welcome we have no more cards on on this
bill uh so we are going to close the
hearing on the base adequacy portion of
this and we're going to move into the
next bill which deals with the
differentiated Aid component of special
education and a lot of the discussion
here on this one is going to be very
similar to what we heard I'm I'm sure um
just a little background for where we've
been as a policy Committee in the past
we recognize the need for a weighted
formula in this
category
um uh the present allocations $2,100
this this uh particular Bill moves it to
27,000 so representative do you have a a
pink card for us did I submitted it
earlier you got it ear oh it's on the
same okay yes welcome thank you um again
I'm representative Lauren seelig I
represent Durham New Hampshire and I'm
introducing the bill on behalf of myself
but also representative Kennedy who is
the Prime sponsor um who sent me his
testimony and I'll read that and then
make a couple of additional comments if
you don't mind um thank you Mr chairman
and members of the education committee I
again apologize for not being present as
I'm still in law school classes and I
thank representative selig for
introducing this bill for me this bill
is straightforward and increases the
cost for students receiving special
education services specifically if you
look at section 2D it raises the amount
from
$2,100 to 27,000 for those receiving
special education services as you will
hear testimony from individuals who work
in special education this amount is
what's necessary for student in special
education program to receive an ad
adequate
education and so in addition to
representative Kenny's comments um I
will say I am the proud mother of an IEP
student who is also a member of the
National Honor Society because she is an
incredibly hardworking student but she's
also been able thankfully to receive the
support that she needs um she was
diagnosed as having a learning
disability in second grade um now that
she's a junior in high school her
learning disability has has not
magically disappeared as a lot of Us
wish it would um but we've learned a lot
of strategies to cope with her learning
challenges and to help her be successful
in school um she is a mild learning
disability she is not one of the more
severely uh needy children that we have
in our district um however she meets
with her special education case manager
um three times a week as part of her uh
Services um that case manager also has a
par professional who works with her who
assists my daughter in understanding
things like how to survive chemistry
class um something I'm not sure most of
us could do in regardless of a learning
ability or not um but also as she is
currently in her Civics education class
and fully capable of explaining to her
Civics teacher what it is a state
representative does what the difference
is between state government and local
government but as she prepares for the
um the citizenship test and looks at the
way the questions are structured the
language of those questions is so
confusing to her that she is is unlikely
to pass that test on for multiple
occasions until she can understand the
structure of the question so in order
for her to get the kind of support she
needs someone has to work with her to
help her read through those questions
create some kind of study system so that
she can make sense of what's being asked
it's not that she can't explain the
content it's that much of the time she
is blocked from understanding the way
the questions are phrased right um she
is likely to go on to college and
college thankfully her IEP will follow
her and she be able to get support
services at whatever college she attends
but the cost of educating her is far
more than it was for my daughter who did
not have any special needs and who in
fact was able to tutor peers in her
classes as she went through school she
my older daughter did not require tutor
she did not require someone to sit down
and spend hours breaking down
information into sections and chunking
it out for her she did not require her
classroom teachers to make copies of
notes in advance for her to highlight
and fill in but all of those things are
essential services for my other daughter
who as I said has a mild learning
disability um I have friends whose
daughters have um dyslexia who have all
sorts of additional special needs we
have kids in our district who have Down
syndrome who have a wide variety of
needs and other types of Developmental
delays um and I also have a friend whose
um child has been sent to an outof
District residential placement for six
years those costs are astronomical and
far exceed the 27,000 even listed here
so I urge the committee to recognize
that we need to increase funding as a
state we need to help support our
taxpayers across the state and um I'm
open to taking any questions thank you
thank you very are there any questions
for represent s yes represent
leus yes I was I
was looking at um the numbers and having
a flat rate like
that I wondered what happens in a
district where you have a small district
with a very expensive student student
versus perhaps a larger District that
only has smaller expense students times
27 you would end up with a great
discrepancy and I was wondering if you
were amable to coming up with something
that was
more graduate you know graduated to help
account for those differences yes thank
you so much for the question so I am not
the expert in figuring out all the
financial formulas we do have some
experts here including um Jane berson
who will be testifying shortly who is an
much more of an expert in this field and
may be able to give you more Nuance
numbers I'm not sure if that's what
she'll be able to do or not I I don't
have an objection to um the state
structuring it in such a way that we are
making sure that we're funding
appropriately based on the number of
special education students again there
are some students who require a huge
dollar amount and some who require a
smaller dollar amount um but
proportionately across the state I think
the percentages of special education
students District to District are
similar it's just that the costs vary
depending on on what the needs are and
where they are and very year to year
right as people relocate and as people
graduate thank you before we go with any
further questions in the area of special
education here there's two sources of
revenue for special education in the
state and one of those we're not
involved with that is the catastrophic
we call it special education Aid now
there's a formula once you get three and
a half times the average cost then you
go up 80% to 10 times that and and the
state has certain costing
responsibilities in that we're talking
about the portion right now it's
differentiated Aid dealing with 13 IEP
categories um and how we're going to
fund those categories uh so uh let's
stay away from the cat Aid stuff that's
uh totally out of our Bailey wick for
all of us right right here so are there
any further questions for representa
celik thank you very much thank you all
so much and I look forward to seeing you
again um if not later today then later
this
week okay we have Zach Sheen
and is hope I'm a little confused how
here okay you're speaking behalf of
somebody else okay okay you're
welcome hello again Zach Shen um New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project um we're speaking in support of
1656 uh I just want to highlight a few
things some of which some of the
questions we're we're getting at
um since we're now talking we're going
from base Aid to the special education
differentiated Aid piece um currently um
including that in the calculation of
adequacy is on one hand an omission and
acknowledgement by the state that
students who receive special education
services those Services cost more money
they need those services to achieve at
the same level of their peers as you
just heard from the previous
testimony um during the 2021 2022 school
year um just under 30,000 students in
our Public School System receive special
education
services um however the addition $2,100
per student receiving those special
education services does not come even
remotely close to the amount of money it
actually costs to provide these Services
the actual additional funding um if you
take the number of students receiving
the services and number additional Ser
um number of additional funding was
about $28,000 per student so I believe
that's where this $27,000 number came
from yes it's exactly round it's a
starting point it's just about what the
average additional cost actually is by
increasing the special education
differentiate Aid to $227,000 per pupil
it's an equality approach to
representative lak's Point earlier it's
not an equity approach so some districts
would it wouldn't exactly match that up
but it would be a significant step
towards making sure that students are
able to weather the able to provide the
services they need for their students
they are not having as much Financial
fluctuation year-to year special
education costs accounted for about $840
million during the 2021 2022 school year
which about 25% of toal New Hampshire
education expenditures and every school
district shares those responsibilities
and is indeed required by state and
federal law to provide a lot of these
services but just like the rest of our
funding system in New Hampshire most of
that was borne by local property
taxpayers in fact the state only
contributed 7.3% of the actual cost of
special education services through the
adequacy formula if you add on the um
other Aid that was just being mentioned
that's the only 11% of total special
education expenditures that were covered
by the
state due to this broken funding system
and heav Reliance on local property
taxes these changes in funding and the
amount of volatility here really put
strains on everyone's school budget and
specifically smaller School
budgets um hb1 1656 provides you all a
legislative option to move in a positive
direction it might not be the perfect
bill or the perfect number right now but
I really encourage the subcommittee to
take this seriously look at the
discrepancy in current special education
Aid versus actual expenditures
and figure how how to get closer to
providing our schools with the amount of
money that they actually need happy to
answer any
questions any questions from the
much uh that 1656 I have that card and
and I have yours represent Damon to
to
thank you Mr chair good morning
colleagues for the record representative
hope Damon Sullivan District 8 um I am
reading remarks from Timothy Kuman who
is the director of special ed for wiwam
school district because the weather and
his kids Transportation needs prevented
him from being here
unfortunately and so he says bear with
me so I can
see my name is Tim cuman and I'm
currently the director of student
services in the Wescom Regional School
District serving the towns of Northfield
sand Borton and Tilton this is my 25th
year in education all the two of which
has been in the field of special
education much has changed in this field
since 1998 for many parent procedural
safeguards to the prevalence and
significance of disabilities in our
Public School System wanting warranting
more extensive and creative programming
for students with disabilities however
what has changed little over that same
period of time is the extent that the
federal government and the state of New
Hampshire has contributed to districts
to cover necessary costs associated with
all children but especially higher costs
associated with children with
disabilities without going into great
detail regarding my perspective of what
we know is inadequate about the
education funding system in the state I
can confidently tell you that the
financial impact for those that it
burdens the most local taxpayers is
significant whether it is the local
systems requirement to serve all idea
eligible enrolled public school students
in our district schools idea eligible
resident students in any public
chartered school and idea eligible
students requiring substantially
separate programming in approved private
special ed schools the funding sources
available to school districts outside of
local taxpayer funds is limited we have
one Federal idea flowthrough funds that
has been underfunded since idea's
Inception in the mid 70s two special
education Aid which only provides the
district an annual pro-rated amount
often no more than 50% of the total
amount locally expended and three
special education adequacy differential
currently $22,100 per student which is
conservatively 10% of what it actually
costs to address our fiscal obligations
for even a typical student with a
disability I wholeheartedly appreciate
and fully support what the sponsors of
1656 are trying to accomplish by putting
forward this piece of leg
legislation as you can see funding for
special ed has far behind the changing
nature of state and federal law and what
those legal obligations require public
districts to shoulder mostly on their
own as a committee please strongly
consider your support for this bill as
it will put the burden more where it
belongs on the state to provide this
piece of what is considered an adequate
education for at least this aspect of
our student population thank you and I
look forward to further discussion about
how this new law could benefit the
students in New Hampshire respectfully
submitted Tim krian director of student
service Services when school district um
and if I may parenthetically say I
personally know Tim and you could not
imagine a more dedicated
educator thank you thank you very much
seeing you just read that in for Tim
you're not going to take questions for
Kim thank
you so that concludes all the uh cards
Oregon if if you want to speak on this
here these these are all yeah thank you
very much Mr chairman I submitted two
cards at 9:00 or 1686 on the top okay
there it
is yeah yeah yeah all right okay sorry I
TR to they're here go ahead represent my
apologies you're already running behind
schedule another card on top of that yes
I understood yes I was so um I'm a
co-sponsor 1656 and um I think already
sent put out some written testimony
which actually I was going to bring a
print out of for myself but um so and I
don't need read it verbatim anyway so
the uh one thing as the uh and I'm sure
the uh representa Cel my fellow Durham
representative I only saw a little bit
of her uh testimony on uh this the uh on
the Clos caption video but I'm sure it
was excellent and to the point probably
made the point much better than I could
um but so this uh first of all this bill
it is does have a very high price tag um
you know it's pretty uh pretty daunting
actually but both the Department of
Education who wrote the fiscal note and
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project agree well they're off
by a few hundred, but that's uh not much
that's not much money the largest game
of things that it cost the school
districts pay about $685 million for uh
special ed education funding and so the
state only currently only kicks in about
uh 35 million so this will um ask the
state to raise $650 million of
luckily the way this bill is written
unlike the previous one they don't have
to do that until uh July 1st 2025 which
means both the spending and the revenue
will also have to be dealt with by
you know the next legislature probably
by the law of averages about a third of
us will move on to other things by then
um but most of us will still be around
and we'll still be and all of us will
still be concerned about these issues
but um and that's a daunting it's a
daunting task but I I think it can be
done when way as I said this state wi
property tax I'm not a big fan of it but
it does exist it does work um and people
would actually not see much difference
their tax bills that they would get even
though they still be absurdly high won't
be any higher or much different than
they would be otherwise
and and so the same arguments about
fairness because school districts have
different uh resources apply to if that
applies to this bill there's also
additional fact that it's kind of random
so like uh there's some special
education uh cases that are you know
some of them are fairly small amounts of
money fairly simple uh things that have
to be done to enable the the child to
learn some
require h sums of money and it's kind of
a so even though the number of students
who have INF IEPs well are it's a fairly
that's a little bit less than 20% I
think anyway it's a fairly predictable
percentage but it's you don't really
know when your school district is going
to get a catastrophic case like that and
we do have ways of dealing with it I
think probably the easiest way is just
to um smooth it out and this is a way of
spreading it over the entire state which
is fairer also the current system
discriminates somewh people either from
towns poorer towns or families from
towns of or families in general who have
uh fewer resources because if your
family is is well off you know they'll
put a lot of they'll be able to put a
lot of more own resources into it and
some on who are less well off after
theyve been in the school districts U so
I think this is a this is a fair Bill
it'll it's a and it'll like enable it'll
enable more students to get the services
they need and it will reduce the uh
unpredictably inde prence on the test
payers so that's uh that's why and I
probably replicated everything rep sik
says but U I thought I'd put in my two
cents anyway or my $685 million as the
case may be and you thank you very much
thanks are there any
it
good
morning good morning my name is Jane
berson bullu and I am the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association of special ed administrators
and I am here today representing over
250 leaders in the field of special
education uh who are supporting this
bill um as you know we're a nonprofit
organization um our members come from
throughout the entire State they are
public school leaders as well as those
from our approved private special
education schools some of them um are
residential uh programs and when we
think about um HP 1656 from our lens it
really begins to identify the challenges
that you've heard about specifically the
financial challenges and the inequities
uh related to special education funding
in our various School communities as we
all know the field of special special
education is very complex and it's bound
by state and federal special education
rules which enable us to provide a free
and appropriate special education to um
all students within our communities
you've heard about the average cost for
educating a student uh with an IEP when
you look at the study um that the uh
commission did on education um the cost
for um educating a student is between
with with an IEP is between 35 and
$40,000 and the numbers of students uh
with IEPs in the state of New Hampshire
continue to increase as do the uh
complexities of the disabilities that
we're seeing within uh the children in
in our communities so in summary um HB
1656 is really worthy of attention we
will hope that you will continue to
support it as it goes through the
committee process in hopes that it will
begin to address some of the challenges
related to uh funding for special
education in New Hampshire thank you
very much for your time and for your
service uh to the citizens of New
Hampshire uh thank you for your
testimony uh representative Miler thank
you Mr chair thank you for being here
You' indicated in your testimony that
there's been an increase in the number
of special education coded children is
there a basis for that increase since we
also have a decrease in student
population I think you know ferally when
we talk to our um folks and when we talk
to our own members we're seeing a wide
variety of reasons for this one of which
um was covid and you know the the lack
of Education that students got and they
um were exposed to a lot of trauma
during that time we're also seeing um
the impact of um the opioid crisis um
and a lot of students um in families
that are opioid involved um we're seeing
um a lot of mental health challenges uh
with students for a variety of different
reasons you know so those those are just
some of the examples of you know reasons
um that we're seeing a bit of an
increase are there further questions
represent cordelli thank you thank you
for your testimony um do you have any
idea where the
$227,000 number came from I was not a
further
questions thank you very much thank you
Trumble good morning again David Trumble
from the town aware speaking on special
education this bill is something that I
live with every day my dear wife is a
lifelong special education teacher of
going on 40 years so when I ask how was
your day we're talking about how was
special education in the public schools
today so I want to start with bringing
this back to people that special
education students what I've learned is
are amazing students and people and they
deserve to be treated with respect like
every other student their legal rights
need to be respected like every other
students in our state's constitutional
duty to fund their education exists like
every other student there should be no
question that we should fully fund
special ed at the state
level the rights that special ed
students come from a variety of federal
laws but they have the right to a free
and appropriate education regardless of
the nature and severity of their
disability and they have the right to
receive a compr able education to
students without disabilities the
federal government lists like 13
different categories of disabilities it
includes hearing impairments Vision
impairments speech or language
impairments Orthopedic impairments other
health impairments intellectual
disabilities specific learning
disabilities serious emotional
disturbances autism autism spectrum
disorder traumatic brain injury death
blindness multiple disabilities and
developmental delays it's a wide range
of amazing students that we're talking
about here I don't know which set of
numbers is easier for you to understand
so I'll try a couple different
approaches one is the pi approach the
town's share of the pie is 81% the
state's share of the pie is 11% and the
fed's share of the pie is 7% if you go
more for dollars towns pay
$36,000 per student the state only pays
about $5,000 per student if you're more
interested in well how much of this as
of a local school budget the average in
the state is a quarter 25% of the school
budgets but in many school districts
it's as high as 40 or 45% there's no way
that that school can function properly
with such a high percentage so what what
does this mean in the real world it
comes down to choices the school
district in the schools have to say we
have to by federal law provide special
education services how do we do this how
do we provide that to every special Edge
student every non-s specialed student
and keep the lights on and the roof
fixed and the fields fixed if puts towns
and cities in a dilemma to make
educational choices the special ed
students end up getting the brunt of it
because people are resentful of that and
that's not fair it's the state's failure
to fund that creates that crisis in the
first place you have an obligation to
fund these students and we should live
up to it as a
state that's our legal obligation
there's also a moral obligation there's
an old saying that budgets are
statements of values when the state only
spends 11% of what's needed for special
ed students which is lower than for
non-sp special ed students and not near
its obligation that's telling these
students that they are not as valuable
and we need to fix that thank you very
much for your time thank you very much
David are there any
questions not see thank you very much
you're welcome uh next one is Jennifer
belmonti or
Belmont it goes off the card the rest of
good morning good morning Miss Belmont
Earl was unable to stay she had a
childcare emergency she has asked me to
present on her behalf if that's fine
that's fine good board thank you um for
the record my name is Michaela Deiter I
am speaking on behalf of uh Jennifer
Belmont Earl uh of barington and uh
everything that I'm about to say are her
exact
words thank you chairman Rick lad and
House Education committee my name name
is Jennifer Belmont Earl I live in
barington New Hampshire with my husband
and our two school-aged children when
you are the parent of autistic children
you learn not to trust people will the
parents of that child yell at your kid
because your son has grabbed another
child's hand to communicate where did
that group of 5-year-old girls learn the
tone of voice to taunt and belittle your
child on the playground and why don't
their parents step in why aren't you
welcome in public spaces this is why I
was shocked and amazed at the way the
special education teachers classroom
teachers occupational and speech
therapists embraced both of my boys in
the barington school district they
worked together to help my children
participate in their classes and to help
them make friends my older son's
classroom teacher believed me when I
said I thought the excessive noise in
the cafeteria was the reason he pushed
another child in line she reminded Sammy
to put on his noise cancelling
headphones there was no repeat incident
my younger son's classroom teacher and
amazing one-on-one have helped Zeke
Express his interest in other children
in his integrated public preschool these
children know that his way of
communicating with them involves his
touching their arms or hair smiling and
running his classmates sit with him at
his table to eat snacks they benefit
from Zeke's presence and want to be his
friend if you aren't the parent of a
child with disabilities you might not
understand how exceptional this is the
terror of children who are isolated
bullied and harmed in our Public Schools
haunts me the experience of each child
varies by School District in part
because the state has abdicated its
responsibility to adequately fund
special education leaving it up to the
districts themselves this has set up an
eerie echo of my grandparents generation
where parents out of necessity educated
their children at home or at parent L
and funded schools like the Great Bay
School these were the only alternatives
to the state run lonia state school I
encourage those who do not know about
lonia to familiarize themselves with its
history our public schools are not the
hell lonia was however I know too many
parents who have felt the need to pull
their children from public schools
because of the lack of adequate
resources pass this bill because all of
New Hampshire's students deserve the
excellent education my boys already
enjoy thank you thank you very much do
you have copies of that for us uh she
included one so I'm happy to turn in one
she also did tell me that she submitted
it electronically last night thank you
very
much uh any question Jennifer
Earl that's that was her that was oh
excuse me excuse me wake up okay there
were two cards
yeah
and
uh Milani is
it
he
cown good morning thank you to the
committee for allowing me to speak with
you today I did bring copies of my
testimony with me um we've had some
great testimony that I think summarizes
really adequately a lot of what I was
going to say but I would like to talk to
you today about um personal experience
uh first of all my name is Melanie
renfer Hebert I'm from gtown New
Hampshire where we absolutely have the
absolute best school system um schools
in New Hampshire I'm certain um I'm a
community Economic Development
specialist by trade and um I also am
active in my town so I'm familiar with
the processes of budgeting um and other
um aspects of of our our running our
school and the costs that are associated
with it um I'm also the very proud
parent of two children um who have um
are both individuals with
disabilities and receive Services
through our school
system um I am keenly aware that my
children are very different and have
very different needs as do all the
children who are receiving special
education um in the state of New
Hampshire and around our country um for
me I'm aware that um while one child has
very low needs um in terms of services
and supports that are have been provided
by our school system since the day he
walked into the school um at three years
old um and will continue through to um
to his high school years um the other
one uses
approximately the same amount of
services and EXP expense for one child
as it would if every child in his
classroom had to receive the same s had
to receive a regular
education and I'm aware um very keenly
aware of how that affects our school
budget and the ability of our schools to
um provide
services that would benefit all
students um I'm a strongly supporting
this bill um because it will make
available more funds to provide services
to other students in our town as well um
I know we we we have the benefit of um
you know scale in our schools and we can
provide services but special education
is not one of them special education is
extremely personal extremely
individualistic and extremely important
as these individuals are part of our
community and in my case part of my
family um and our town does an amazing
job but it can't do it without adequate
funding to support special education so
I'm asking you today the entire
committee committee to please support
adequate funding for special education
in New Hampshire thank you thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee thank you thank you if you
could drop that off we can put that
right into the record your report there
are there any other folks that have
cards for this one because we're at the
end of this we're ready to go into the
next uh bill so I will close this
hearing just one little comment about
special education we all recognize
that's extremely important in the state
one of the issues we're grappling with
is the federal government initially said
they pay 40% of the cost they're down
somewhere between 9 to 10% of our bud
you know they have significantly reduced
Monies to this state in terms of special
education support so it's being passed
down to all of us
and we got to deal with that so what
we're going to do for the committee I'm
going to give them about five minutes to
shake it out a little bit here stand up
as educators are advised to have people
do and and and get a drink of water
there's this is a very dry atmosphere in
here uh take your fluids and we'll come
back in about 5 minutes and pick the
hand
there's an unknown cost area that we're
not addressing because it doesn't fit
the
think again today the next uh Bill we
have is HP
1586 establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education the prime sponsor of
that bill is represent luno
representative luno the floor is yours
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the uh the committee uh for the
record my name is Dave luno and uh
represent uh uh the people of marac
County District 9 which are folks that
live in Hopton and bow but uh I see my
responsibility and and all of our
responsibilities as uh as being
Statewide so I'm really happy to uh to
be in in this uh in in your presence
this morning to introduce House Bill
1586 um 1586 is a little bit different
than the last two bills that we heard it
is um been described uh a few different
ways uh I've described it as
comprehensive school funding reform uh
other people have described it as a
school funding overhaul uh for New
Hampshire but its official title is a
foundation opportunity budget plan and
and much of it um came out of the work
that was done by the commission to study
school funding back in 2020 and uh and
evidence for that is in in the
commission's uh report um fundamentally
what it is is um is uh a little bit of a
pretty significant departure from how we
currently fund our schools based on a um
sort of a formula that uh that treats
all school districts equally the um the
1586 Foundation opportunity budget
design is really about Equitable school
funding Equitable for students and
Equitable for taxpayers and so um I'd
like to just take not a whole lot of
time uh this morning because as as chair
lad has indicated we've got a work
session day coming up tomorrow that I
think we can really get into the Weeds
on on all these bills and I think
there'll be even future work sessions on
that so I'd like to try to try to
somewhat stay at the uh at the you know
30,000 foot U level when 50,000 I'll go
up to 50 I'll go up to 50,000 so so as
long as the door in the back of the
plane doesn't blast right this is not a
last a yeah
yeah so um um so in the in the in the
nutshell uh 1586 addresses the four
points from The Claremont uh Claremont 1
decision and the four points are Define
an adequate
education cost it fund it and provide
accountability uh to it and um let me
just take a take a minute to talk about
how 1586 does this currently we Define
an adequate education this came up in an
earlier uh discussed on earlier Bill Uh
current law defines an adequate
education uh as uh in in what's called
terms of inputs so how many things a a
school districts uh School District
needs to have in order to uh to operate
so so and uh these things are actually
what you sort of think they are uh how
many U how many student you know what
one 130th of a teacher in a classroom 30
desks 30 chairs one 500th of a principal
you know books on the shelf stuff stuff
like that 1586
instead looks at it differently it it
defines um an adequate education in
terms of student performance so in terms
of student outcome and um and in general
that's something that we can be very
proud of in in New Hampshire because our
average performing student in New
Hampshire uh performs among the best um
in the country but uh but as as
indicated you know through earlier
testimony on other bills it's just not
happening in all of our school districts
so uh so and that's where um that's
where rightsizing these budgets really
can can come in to make sure districts
have have uh have the budgets they need
to to be able to um to educate their
students to a Statewide outcome so we
Define an adequate
education in terms of student outcome
Statewide Statewide outcome we cost it
that's the second thing so so how do we
go about costing um education for a
Statewide Statewide outcome well the
commission actually looked at 10 years
worth of data uh collected by the
department from every school district
across the state looked at student
outcomes uh in all of those districts
and were able to connect uh costs for
certain things with student outcomes and
and remarkably as uh as has been
testified earlier as far as the base
cost is concerned it really lined up
very close to what uh to an an
input-based uh um uh costing model uh
looks like but what it allows us to do
is also look at the other factors that
go that that are cost drivers for an
adequate education and these are things
that we're all familiar with from the uh
from the current school funding model
special education free and reduced price
lunch English language Learners and um
and for for these things um you could we
you you'd actually see in 1586 that for
free and U while the while the base
would be around that
$7,400 Mark the free and reduced price
lunch uh premium would be closer to
$10,000 per student in that ADM uh
$112,000 per students that are English
language Learners and
$27,000 for for students at special
education right on The Mark with the
actually the last bill that uh uh that
we heard um so that's the second piece
costing it the third piece funding it
and this is where where 1586 takes a a
very different tact from our current um
um funding scheme um 1586 rather than
starting with State
dollars and ending with local dollars
which is what our current current model
does we start with local dollars
and if that doesn't get you to your
foundation opportunity budget then the
state comes in and gets you there so the
state guarantees the funding for that uh
for that budget make sure you can get
get you there we heard from from several
superintendents that hey we just can't
get there we've got a tax cap and we
can't get there we've got low property
values we can't get there we've got high
needs we can't get there we cost it and
we fund it and the state make sure you
can get there and then the last part is
providing accountability to this and
while the current model has a input
based and outcomes based is such a such
a a great opportunity to provide
accountability because it's the type of
accountability I think we all like to
talk about how are our students
doing and if they're not doing that well
on average in a certain District let's
make sure we we give them some help in
terms of uh in terms of how to how to
get there and um and and and so tying
that accountability to student outcomes
goes right back to the definition of
adequacy in
1586 um so so uh let's see uh we we
talked about how um how 1586 leans into
the conval decision given the uh the
base cost that it uh that it uses but it
also leans into the Rand order as well
and contains a um uh a section that uh
that implements um reform of the
Statewide education property tax I know
there's another bill we're going to be
hearing uh I think at the end of the day
this or at the end of the afternoon that
does the same thing as um as that so so
we're leaning into Claremont conal and
Rand um 1586 has no fiscal note yet
clearly there would be a fiscal note um
but um but if we take a look look
at the 1586 is predecessor which some on
this committee may remember from
20202 uh House Bill 1680 there while
there wasn't a fiscal note on that
either we did receive information from
the uh from the Department on um on what
the uh what the cost would look like
what the total State cost would be and
what uh how that would translate down to
uh cities and towns uh throughout the
state and um remark ably the uh when you
compare those spreadsheets from from
2022 which refer the for the fy2 24 and
fy2 uh school years the years that we're
in right now on this current budget the
total State share is um right around the
same like plus or minus $10 million out
of a you know obviously much higher
number than that so so they came in very
much on par um so what does this mean
mean for the most challenged cities and
towns across the state and uh we heard
from SE several of them this morning um
uh in FY 24 right now on our actual
school funding formula um Berlin
receives $ 11.5 million from the um from
the state and under the bill we've got
in front of us right now that would go
up by over a million do Claremont
receives $15.6 million from State under
current law that would go up again uh by
almost um actually over $2 million
because of $17.7 million um Pittsfield I
think we heard we heard about Pittsfield
uh earlier currently receives $5.3
million from the state that would go up
to 6.4 and Newport and we heard uh we
heard some very I think moving uh
stories and facts from uh from and the
challenges that Newport faces goes from
8.3 $ million under current law to $10.1
uh million and uh that's in the first
year of a phase in uh of a seven-year
phase in uh that um that
1576 uh 1586 sorry contemplate so
um let's
see just want to make sure I'm sort of
covering uh uh things at the 50,000 foot
level without flying out the back door
um uh I think there's changes that uh
that that um that 1586 is going to
require in order to um uh to be workable
since it was a a copy from what we did
three years ago obviously things have
changed property values have changed the
current school funding formula the in
law uh has changed and um and
enrollments have changed too so we would
need to address all of all these factors
in uh in New finan Financial um in in
new new spreadsheets so um so I guess in
summary I would uh I would basically say
that um that 1586 is a strong framework
for um uh for robust school funding it
doesn't have a left half SL right half
side of the formula where the right half
props up the left half it's just the
formula and the formula Works uh doesn't
have a hold harmless again not something
that that that propping up a formula
that doesn't work um uh it's it's
costing and funding it's defining
adequacy defining adequacy in terms of
student outcome um and um and you know I
think it's something that uh that that
we've been waiting for here in New
Hampshire that uh doesn't require us to
um to necessarily Envision um new
Revenue sources we can work within the
state's current Revenue model uh for
this so um so I I hope um that sort of
sets a reasonable stage for uh for the
hearing this morning and for the work uh
work ahead and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you very much represent
luno are there any questions from the
committee yes represent
leus I have two questions and I went
over this again this morning with my
husband and so some of these were sort
of joint questions
um my first question about the add the
um accountability I'm curious why you're
only doing accountability for
underperforming schools instead of that
those accountability things are are
great why are you not doing them for all
the schools yeah that's a that's a great
question and uh and I I think
accountability should be done for for
all the schools I think that's an area
we can work on together and um and you
know in particular when you look at the
accountability uh portion of Bill I
think the bill is something like 25 26
pages and I think it's a good third of
it is probably accountability and uh a
lot of it is has to do with data
collection um and uh being able to make
sure that we're collecting the the the
best data to be able to um to see how
students are doing and hold um I don't
say hold school districts accountable
but it is holding School District it's
providing them the hand they need to
make sure that during their budgeting
process they're applying the foundation
opportunity budget that uh that that
moves the for their kids and then the
second question I may um I'm
wondering it I maybe I missed it but
what
happens if a school does not meet the
goals what is what other
than having them come up with a plan Etc
but what what then happen yeah the
department gives them some help in in
terms of their their you know U their
their budget plan and the foundation
opportunity budget is is defined pretty
well the total the the bottom line cost
is defined pretty well we know what goes
into the bottom line cost based on what
districts are currently doing and uh and
certainly you know we can the the
department would be able to help in
terms of well maybe you want to look at
this type of programming or or do
something different that's that's going
to um really um be be responsive to
students interests and and their uh
their their um um uh educational
outcomes okay thank you thank you for
the question forther questions from the
committee not seeing any hands thank you
very much thank you very much Mr chair
thank you members of committee like call
Ames
hi so I'm pleased to be here I was
honored to serve on the uh commission
that studied school funding a few years
ago um and my time in uh looking at
school funding issues actually goes back
very long way I started out in
Massachusetts in
1979 I think it was I was General
Council for the Secretary of Education
in
Massachusetts and uh papers were served
as I said there um in the very first
school funding litigation in
Massachusetts which was based on
constitutional Provisions that are in
the Massachusetts Constitution that that
are very similar to the provisions that
are in the New Hampshire
Constitution and that case um which had
a different name then but became the
McDuffy
case um led to a conclusion by the
Massachusetts
court try to get it right
here um the Massachusetts Supreme Court
which is called the mass to the Supreme
Judicial Court
um invalidated the Commonwealth's then
school funding system and made two
distinct Holdings that the state's
Constitution's education Clause imposes
on the Commonwealth an enforceable duty
to provide a public education for all
its children rich and poor in every city
and town and that the Commonwealth had
failed to satisfy that Duty in the case
of the students from property poor
communities who were plaintiffs in the
case that all I'm sure sounds familiar
to you that kind of situation so here we
are in massach in New Hampshire and uh
the McDuffy court that I just quoted
from uh came was handed down in June
1993 well uh it wasn't long after that
that uh the uh Claremont one decision in
December
1993 was handed down the New Hampshire
Supreme
Court uh looked and quoted from the
McDuffy case the Massachusetts case in
several places in their opinion and like
the uh McDuffy case found that the
education Clause now were into the New
Hampshire
Constitution uh imposes a duty on the
legislative and executive branches of
State government and to quote uh the New
Hampshire Court we hold that part two
article 83 imposes a duty on the state
to provide a constitutionally adequate
education to every educable child in the
public schools in New Hampshire and to
guarantee adequate funding end quote and
in doing that they gave weight to the
McDuffy case because they said New
Hampshire modeled its constitution on
Massachusetts
Constitution and included in that
Constitution a nearly this is quoting
the uh the uh New Hampshire Court uh
including a quote nearly identical
provision regarding education
unquote um so fast forwarding to our
situation now um well let me let me uh
first say that uh pursuant to the
McDuffy case Massachusetts went on to
work within the legislature under uh the
threat of further judicial intervention
to create a comprehensive school funding
system that's known in Massachusetts as
the Chapter 70 programs that that's a
chapter of their general laws and uh
that's a very comprehensive um system
that's been modified as years have gone
by but it stood the test of time and uh
the fun on the funding side of that it
by the way is an input based system we
talked earlier about input based and
outcomes based ways of figuring out what
the uh uh cost of an adequate education
is but um the Massachusetts uh came down
with an input based system and for the
funding for the funding of that system
they established
uh essentially let's call it two
sources uh one is local and the other is
state to meet that constitutional
obligation so um this there's a a
minimum contribution provision in the
Massachusetts system and then state aid
and the minimum contribution which is
locality by locality and comes out of
property tax revenues it varies
inversely
with the property tax wealth of a
particular uh Community um so a poor
Community uh facing significant
educational costs would be expected to
uh pay a much smaller share of the cost
of what they call a foundation budget uh
which is the phrasing actually in the
bill before you um uh than a a
well-to-do uh District which would pay
uh more like uh 85 to 100% of the cost
uh out of their local property tax
revenues um and that's basically the
system in in 16 in uh in 15 I almost
said 1680 1586 well it was 1680 it looks
very similar it does uh so um let me
just get over to one last part of this
but way a lot of this material that I
grabbed when I realized I I might uh my
talk here is from the um commission's
report the published report it's in the
appendix I think it's appendix C of the
uh commission's report uh and it
discusses this question of uh of state
and local contributions and the
constitutionality of them um and I would
say that uh our court that uh the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has never
examined a system similar to what has
been done in Massachusetts the Chapter
70 program which is a system which
requires communities to exercise their
local property tax power to raise a
strict minimum local contribution that
is designed by the state to vary Inver
inversely with local community wealth
and that must be devoted to meeting the
foundation budget in our case the
adequacy spending requirement all of
which operate together in a highly
integrated manner with state aid to
achieve um a good result and um the the
uh uh one other aspect of this uh way of
approaching things that I would
underscore is
that it it reflects a a concept that I I
think is fundamental to the way uh in
which um public
education um should be provided there's
a partnership between the state and the
local um local school districts it's not
the state uh telling the localities what
to do and providing all the money it's a
shared obligation and responsibility
overseen by the state because the state
is the enforcer of the Constitution but
uh essentially Mo all education is
happening at the local level and the
funding is as I've described it uh in
that system and in the system that's
proposed here by um by in this bill and
the last thing I'd say is that I fully
recognize that uh there is language that
has been used by our court uh over the
years since the first uh Claremont
decision um that might give uh that does
give um support to the view that the
state has to pay every last cent of the
cost of an adequate education and
nothing can come out of the
localities um but I I believe as I said
before that the Irish court has never
directly addressed that issue in the
context of a system that is designed
carefully to be responsible and to
ensure that uh there's an successful uh
uh outcome to uh The Joint Partnership
of the state and locality and uh um we
may need to uh we may need that input
from the uh uh Supreme Court to go
forward but I think there's nothing
stopping this legislature from making
its own judgments about what is
appropriate and uh the degree to which
it can vary from um The View that uh all
all must be paid for by the state once
it's defined as adequacy I think we can
do differently than that and I think we
must in order to succeed in our Endeavor
to get over this hurdle and finally go
forward on uh uh a fully funded adequate
education program in uh uh or a fully
funded Foundation program and whatever
you want to call it uh in uh New
Hampshire that works well for everybody
and that uh uh gets us off of being
stuck because we can't pay for it thank
you very much representative um yes that
is a hurdle
but we'll deal with it uh questions from
the committee representa cordelli thank
you thank you representative Ames for
being here and your testimony um you
mentioned um you're not telling
municipalities what to do but it seems
to me you are doing exactly that on page
17 with mandated property tax relief
even specifying household income amounts
AR aren't you dictating or wouldn't the
state be dictating to municipalities
what they should be doing I'm not sure
to do do you want to get are you getting
down to a lower level here where we
can't do that tomorrow
all right you know because represent
Ames is on that committee and you're on
that committee too we can have a nice
chat we can have a good chat there you
go representative cascaden thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh representative
for taking my question and I'm not sure
if you if you know this answer but just
to get an example or um a monetary
estimate on what the McDuffy case uh how
after that settlement how the state of
Massachusetts um
you know settle that to be able to pay
for their adequacy I mean what what was
the source of Revenue and do you have
any idea how much they needed to raise I
believe that
um uh sorted out in Massachusetts so
that
roughly
um roughly 42 or 43% something like that
is uh is um
oh
boy I think that that's the state dollar
amount um and then um there's maybe 10%
Federal money and uh the rest would be
uh from the local property
tax and that it varies greatly from
Community to
community follow up yeah we will be
having another person speaking I might
be able to give you that question yeah
and uh and please understand
I couldn't hear you yeah that's fine
yeah and and I just uh I've given you
some numbers and I stand to be corrected
if I'm wrong thank you very much thank
you I think we'll go on to the next uh
presenter here and I'd like to have
Andrew
yours minutes no no because we only have
a couple here
yeah we don't have a lot of cards like
before on this one I me to good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee uh
thank you for allowing me to testify my
name is Andrew balinsky uh I happen to
live in East conquer my wife Amy and I
have three children of whom we're very
proud our son Josh is a middle school
science teacher at a public school in
Denver our daughter Molly was a social
worker in a challenging High School in
Harlem for 5 years and our other
banker um I I want to preface my remarks
in two ways uh first I really like and
respect dick Ames um I listen to what he
says um I'm troubled that I am here
to contest part of his
testimony uh and though although I
respect the sponsors of this bill
um their position to me is heartbreaking
because I think the bill violates the
New Hampshire
Constitution as it was described and
explained in the Claremont and London da
decisions and I'll get into that um the
other
preface is I'm just blown away by the
testimony you've heard this morning and
I hope it's had an impact on you school
districts are struggling across the
state which means administrators and
teachers and other educators are
struggling and of course this impacts
the children in our school districts and
our economy as you've heard John Adams
one of the fathers of Education in our
country wrote the Massachusetts
education Clause we lifted it from
Massachusetts and the purpose of that
Clause is to is to protect the
Democracy that's why we have education
in the Constitution and it happens to be
in the part of the Constitution part two
that deals with the form of government
it's not in part one where individual
rights are so that gives you a flavor
for how uh the founders thought about
education in this
context so I was lead counsel in the
Claremont cases I am co-counsel now in
the Rand litigation case one of the two
pending cases uh in uh on November 20th
judge ruoff issued his partial decision
in our case about the swept the rest of
our case uh as uh my colleague in the
case Natalie laflam U mentioned is
ongoing my other state colleague is John
Tobin uh another lawyer from conquer um
The Claremont principles can be boiled
down to one
paragraph the state has a
responsibility to define the components
of a constitutionally adequate
education in a clear Common Sense
generally understandable
fashion once those components are
identified they need to be fairly and
objectively costed
out once that costing out
occurs the state needs to pay for
everything everything that it's that it
has identified as a component of a
constitutionally adequate education that
is what our court has said
repeatedly and fourth there needs to be
an accountability component of the
definition and so you don't have to take
my word for it with your permission I
just want to quote four sentences from
the London Dairy School District case
this was 2006 this is after all the
Claremont cases were finished Justice
Hicks for the court wrote quote any
definition of constitutional adequacy
crafted by the political branches must
be sufficiently clear to permit common
understanding and allow for an objective
determination of costs whatever the
state identifies as comprising
constitutional adequacy it must pay for
none of that financial obligation can be
shifted to local school districts
regardless of their relative wealth or
need that's just one paragraph from
probably a dozen or 14 decisions on the
subject from our Supreme Court so what
is my coral and why do I oppose
1586 um switches the way in which the
state defines adequacy from an input to
an output model in and of itself that's
not a
problem but in
switching the bill produces what is
essentially a successful schools model
it tells you the scores that must be
achieved without identifying the
components in those successful schools
that make them
successful and so without identifying
the components you can't fairly and
objectively cost out
adequacy and not to be
unfair the legislature doesn't deserve
the benefit of the doubt in costing out
adequacy it needs to be able to show its
homework how did you arrive at the
number in
question and without identifying the
components in a
sufficiently clear way that permits a
common
understanding we're all left to guess so
it's a retreat from Claremont and
londondary in that
regard the bill then chooses to adopt a
targeted Aid
model both representative luno and
representative
Ames have in passing made clear why that
model was adopted it was adopted because
it cost less than fairly paying for
adequacy and targeted Aid which is
different from
Massachusetts to paying for adequacy
which is the New Hampshire standard is
not permitted under our state
constitution as repeatedly interpreted
by our Supreme Court I I'm might add
that John and Natalie and I interact
with our colleagues Across the Nation
who do this kind of funding and we
understand that New Hampshire has set
one of the highest standards in the
nation for the educational Protections
in our Constitution and that's because
we were successful in
marrying educational adequacy
for the benefit of school
children and taxpayer equity for the
benefit of the people who have to pay
for
education and the latter total credit
goes to John Tobin who insisted we
pursue both prongs and fortunately our
court adopted and made rulings on both
prongs that is why the standard is so
high I'd like to say a word about the
commission that's been repeatedly
mentioned I don't know if the members of
this committee know how that commission
came apart came to
be it happened because a series of
events led John Tobin Doug Hall and me
to present over 70 seminars across this
state called Ed funding
101 where we taught citizens how
education funding Works in this state
that was such a successful effort that
we three approached the house leadership
at the time and asked them to convene
what became this commission and to fund
it and I'm sad to say that the
commission didn't finish all of its work
it was supposed to look at funding
sources in addition to defining adequacy
it was to establish the components of
adequacy that our Supreme Court
requires I understand that people like
uh Representatives aim Ames and luno and
Miler and my friend bill aringer is
going to speak after me all support a
targeted Aid approach and they were all
instrumental in the commission's work
but that doesn't make it
constitutional
I want to add one word about
accountability which uh representative
Lex leus
mentioned there is an account
accountability provision in HB
1586 that requires the superintendent in
an unsuccessful District to create a
report about how to improve and to get
St stakeholder Buy in there's no extra
money in that bill for a struggling
District there's no specific requirement
of how the state will help that
struggling
district and it's almost as if the
drafters were unaware of the federal
legislation on
this there is a portion of Essa which is
the big
federal education plan that sets
standards for what are called
comprehensive support and improve
schools they are schools with the lowest
5% of Title One scores and the lowest
graduation rates for a high
school these schools get special money
and special assistance to
improve currently Franklin has two
schools on this list Manchester has two
schools and NASA has two schools there's
a second category called targeted
support and Improvement for schools that
are just a little less
bad Stevens High School Franklin High
School uh two the Manchester High
Schools new high school summersworth
high school are all on that list and
they're all currently getting extra fed
money and extra um assistance in
designing programs to improve their
outputs we don't need a redundant
program that requires superintendent to
do work that's going to get filed on a
shelf if a district is failing we need
to help that District
improve that often
requires careful support and additional
resources and this bill doesn't quite do
that so um I
I I know MC Duffy was
mentioned I'm friends with the lawyers
who litigated McDuffy I know exactly
what it means I know exactly why the
Massachusetts legislature went in One
Direction and why our direct our
legislature cannot go in the same way
and I'm happy to offer whatever
assistance I possibly can in this regard
um I thank you for your time and your
attention um happy to answer any
questions you might have very much I
guess we can blame John Adams for all
this right John Adams my hero sir and
yes you
may so are there any questions committee
we still have a couple left so thank you
very much and we do have the
subcommittee meeting uh tomorrow and uh
there's going to be a lot further
discussion on this regarding the report
and and what we've been heard already
from representa Ames and from you and
now from dick aringer or Bill AR bill
you Bill maybe you've been better off
you brought past to do this for you she
would be much better than I at this uh
with her experience with education uh
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee happy New Year uh my name is
Bill ardinger I'm an attorney in
conquered New Hampshire at the law firm
wrath young and
Pignatelli um I want to just for
disclosure mentioned that our firm
represents clients on policy matters in
front of the legislature on a couple of
them I'm actually registered as a
lobbyist I'm not here today on behalf of
my firm our clients or or but on on
behalf of myself and therefore this is
uh uh an important issue but I wanted to
make sure uh that I disclose the fact
that our firm does Lobby on other
matters um I am uh and attorney with
wrath young as I mentioned uh but I grew
up in Cornish New Hampshire I went to
Stevens High School in Claremont I met
my wife there Cass Spanos uh at Stevens
High School in Claremont um I've been
very lucky uh for the education I
received at Stevens High School
including an English teacher named Paul
magon and I need to a prior uh uh
witness I need to check on something
huh said like yeah that may so so uh um
and um uh my uh children were all
educated in the conquered Public Schools
um my daughter is now special education
teacher in in New York City and in New
York um I am here also because I served
with representative lad uh
representative luno representative Ames
I served on the commission to study
Public Schools I was appointed by and
representative Myer and I was uh
appointed by Governor Chris anunu as his
designate to that commission um I
enjoyed the work on the commission very
much and I fully support the
commission's work and its report um
lastly I would I would mention that um
as part of my interest in this uh that
I've been uh an admirer
of the work that lawyers like attorney
valinsky and attorney Tobin have done to
bring the Claremont litigation
originally and and
Achieve at the very least and we can
I'll focus in close the Claremont one
decision which said that the state of
New Hampshire representative am said
this is responsible for making sure that
every child in this state has access to
to a high
quality public
education and they must make sure that
the funding is there to support that
Duty and fulfillment of that Duty that
is the clont one decision uh like the
McDuffy decision in mass is one of the
best and most historic decisions of our
New Hampshire Supreme Court and I want
to make clear before I go through it
that I support that
why am I a supporter of House Bill uh
1586 and the commission report
because it focuses on an assessment of
the needs of various districts and then
it focuses the
funding on the districts with the
greatest
need so I let's make sense of this I
grew up in Claremont Stevens High School
our education was extremely good there
they face unique challenges there are
other communities in the state that
don't have the same challenges maybe
they don't have as many lowincome
families maybe they don't have as many
students who have uh special needs and
may be uh needing extra services for
special education maybe they have a a
weaker property tax base and they can't
meet the obligations to their children
without um going to specially difficult
burdens I support that house bill 1586
because the formula that's in there ends
up directing more state aid to the
communities with greatest
need um Our obligation under Clara the
legislator's obligation under CL mon is
to
support uh and ensure that and to
guarantee that every child in the state
gets a shot at a good education
regardless of where they live so let's
think about two policy choices one is to
have a formula that identifies special
needs and provides greater help to make
sure that those children don't fall
through an opportunity yeah the other
choice would be to take State money and
divide it among communities on a
uniform per pupil basis take pce base a
and say on a per pupil basis give the
same amount of money to communities that
are wealthier and have fewer challenges
as they would give as the state would
give to communities that have special
needs how does that uniform pay for rule
as a matter of
policy protect our students with the
greatest challenges it doesn't it
doesn't if you have to choose between
one that focuses Aid to help the
communities with the greatest need say
like Manchester students learning
English is a second language conquered
we uh the chain in our student
demographics since when my kids were
here is amazing with students new
Americans who are learning English as a
second language conquered faces greater
challenges than other communities it
should receive greater finance and
resource support this is just a basic
rule a rule that says no everybody gets
every District gets the same amount
regardless of the need and the challenge
that they face to make sure their
children have a fair shot at a decent
education doesn't make sense 1586
changed this it's interesting I my first
experience with this was when I was in
college UNH elected to represent the
town of Cornish and cin uh in this
legislature I served on the ways of
Means Committee but in cin they had a
family that had two children that uh had
very special needs
and it was crippling challenge for the
town of c and at that time I was
advocating the state support and whole
system comprehensive system must provide
greater support to the communities with
the greatest
need I don't hear from leaders in the
litigation like attorney valinsky or
attorney
Tobin a fundamental disagreement with
the equity uh student Equity point that
I'm making it is a different point that
they're focused on they're saying that
the Court Supreme Court has issued a
rule that is kind of this bright line
rule that says you got to give the same
amount per pupil across the entire state
in base Aid above that you can change it
but it's got to be a highly costed
amount and it's got to be split base uh
on a uniform for pupil basis I think
that's where I disagree I don't think
that this court has faced as
representative am said an integrated
comprehensive system of funding and
spending like presented in House Bill
1586 the commission worked on for a year
to develop I don't think they faced it
yet and I don't think they faced an
argument about the consequences Mr
chairman as I'm closing I'd like to
distribute a simple chart that um shows
how every state in the uh country is
divided between
local uh state and federal dollars from
the most recent us sentence 2021 sure
may I distribute yes yeah we'll just
hand it right to represent Bel and
they'll pass them around
cop
and I'll close with this because I know
we're doing a lot your committee your
working committee is going to do a lot
of work on this and I and I look forward
to participating to the extent I'm
allowed to what this uh graphic shows
that's coming around what this chart
shows is based on US Census Data for
2021 how every State's total financing
of their Public Schools is divided
between State revenues as a percentage
local revenues as a percentage Federal
revenues as a percentage all totaling
100% what it shows is that New Hampshire
is one of the lowest States is not
counting District of Columbia the lowest
state in terms of um State percentage
support for the total cost of public
education it shows in contrast
representative cascaden for your work on
the commission I I just it shows in
contrast that
Massachusetts is at uh a little higher
at
41.2% uh State contribution the local
contribution is
53% and the federal uh uh contribution
is
5.8%
it shows that Connecticut is
36.4% state New York
37.8% Pennsylvania
37.4% New Jersey
43.9% Rhode Island
40.4% and New Hampshire as I mentioned
30.9% um if New Hampshire were to adopt
House Bill 1586
the original Finance work that the
commission did would see that the state
contribution would over time increase to
close to 40% of the total which would
put it in line with Massachusetts what
I'd mention is that the states I've just
called out the the the uh the New
England states also are the states with
the highest quality rankings for their
Public School schools New Hampshire is
third in education weeks quality ranking
the two above it are Massachusetts and
New Jersey these uh these states have
some of the lowest state budget
contributions and they have a strong
participation from the local governments
and local control consistent with the
history of New England's commitment to
public education I would say that the
policy job for this legislature is to
say what's the right number what's the
right percentage but as you do it you
need to also make sure that the money
the state money that's put into this is
distributed on a basis that helps make
sure helps in the words of Claremont 1
to
guarantee that every child in this state
has access to a high quality education
regardless of where they live and so
where the greatest challenges are you
don't forget them under
1586 the plaintiff towns for Claremont
do substantially better than they would
under a similarly a uniform based per
pupil distribution that's important for
those of us and there are a lot of us
who care about the communities with the
greatest need thank you thank you very
much Mr aringer so am I correct then
just trying to take away from your
conversation here that we have a
distribution problem yes the uh report
uh for the commission uh concluded that
our current distribution of Education
resources regardless of where the funds
are from local and state total is
regressive and that the way to correct
it the distribution is to make sure that
the communities with the greatest need
get the share they need to give their
children a fair
shot thank you any further questions
from the
committee thank you very much we also
have from the Department of Revenue
Administration Keen M
Wong um I know that this also has some
taxation issues hooked into it we'd be
that good afternoon Mr chair and uh good
afternoon members of the committee my
name is Keen May Wong tax policy Council
of the New Hampshire Department Revenue
um I fully understand that the uh
committee is having a work session
tomorrow a very rigorous work session
tomorrow so I am here to uh distribute a
um fiscal note quick guide uh the Dr did
prepare a fiscal note um it's definitely
very different will be very different
from the uh Department of education's
fiscal note uh and ours focus is more on
the um the swept and the the lower
moderate program um and I'm just going
here
and um so today I just wanted to uh
highlight some items of technical
defects that we noted on on HP
1586 um and the first 158 the first item
would be uh in regards to the amendments
to the swept calc cation the uh the
amendment that was made uh in section
14 um of the proposed Bill use uh States
states that the what page would you be
it will be on page 13 okay on line 32
onwards
okay okay got it and the the amendment
there is on line 33 beginning July 1 of
2025 um and that the the Dr would
calculate the uh the rate to generate
the revenue of $363
million so um that change
sort of disregards the uh the how about
the the fiscal year beginning July one
of 2024 um so that potentially could be
an issue but the Dr assumes that we
would still continue to be calculating
um the the rate for the 363 million for
um fiscal year 202 U fiscal year
beginning July 1 24 um so just wanted to
highlight this that potentially um you
know some additional language needs to
be made to to
to include the uh the uh July 1
2024 um fiscal beginning text year
year the other item that that we sort of
bill section 18 is on page 16 yeah right
Y in this section uh we suggest that
potentially additional language uh to be
included to coincide with the amendment
to a taxable period because the uh the
property tax year taxable period starts
with April
1 um so that would that would avoid any
yeah the other item of note is in the
low and motor program and that would be
17 so in the uh in the calculation here
we noted that uh
the the determination of household
income brackets uh for the applicable
percentage to determine the amount of
low motor relief available for both
single and household or or married for
or married persons uh there is a gap
that happens there uh for the income
level qualifying for the 100% claim and
where the phase out begins so in in in
my handout I provide a uh an example of
that where that Gap occurs so uh during
uh the committee committee's review U
committee should have a look at that
just to determine to make sure that the
corrected and finally uh this is also in
the in the low moderate uh piece where
there is a uh current proposal to have
the limitation of total limitation pay P
out of 25 million per talking about the
exception here excuse me you're talking
about the exception for low and moderate
uh not not the exception but the the the
maximum payout the $25 million payout
yeah um so we think that there
potentially a timing issue right now um
the Dr processes the uh the payout
within 120 days of of receiving the uh
the application for the
relief so in terms of trying to to limit
the payout to $25 million per fiscal
year uh we need to receive
all applications before we can issue any
kind of
payout um and there is language in the
statute to allow for um late submissions
30th okay so the DI would uh suggest the
uh that the committee review this
section uh one more time to make sure
that um that if they intention is to
have that limitation of $25 million per
fiscal year and then how is that going
to pay out play out with the timing of
receiving all the applications uh be it
uh Within by June 30th or with the
extended deadline and uh and the payment
of that uh of the relief
okay and that's all I
have are you going to be around another
question are you going to be around that
you we as a subcommittee working on this
if we have some issues with this portion
of the bill that you would be available
I I will be here as well as uh um we
have we would have uh expert oh well um
a person who's more knowledgeable with
uh with the tax rate calculations um
with us as well okay yes I've been in
discussion with folks over at doe on on
some of this that you're talking about
so yes that'd be great so we we're
meeting um tomorrow and and this part at
from one o'clock on in the afternoon
sure in the morning is not going to be
dealing with this part okay yeah okay
one o'clock okay one o'clock thank you
thank
you are there any questions for the
Dr thank you very much appreciate
it um we do have still several
cards I know we're getting close to
launch here and we'll finish up quickly
leam there you go okay now I'm good all
right um I'm Natalie llam I'm one of the
attorneys for the rans suit resident of
bosin native of Berlin I was not one of
the attorneys on Claremont believe it or
not I was barely alive um which I think
shows how long this has been happening
and I did just want to Circle back about
kind of our concerns with the
Constitution ity of the bill again I was
not on Claremont so this is not just a a
point of Pride or some emotional
connection I have with those decisions
they're just really important to keep in
mind and make sure that any laws you
pass follow those and first as attorney
binsky said it's really good law like if
you look all the education funding
across the state the language in our
Constitution and the way it's been
interpreted by the court is really
really good like other educational
Advocates are jealous of us so I just
it's a shame to kind of brush that aside
with some other kind of uh approach to
it and second the reason that's so
important that it's good language is it
offers protection this is a
constitutional right it's the state's
obligation to fund entirely Fund in
adequate Education First and Last Dollar
if you kind of dilute that principle or
push it aside there's there's no
protection anymore and sure you might
send some targeted a this year next
budget cycle maybe you've changed your
mind mind and you're not going to now
and if you've somehow taken away the
concept the principle that it's the
state's obligation to fund everything
you've just thrown that away and maybe
that right's not coming back so um and
same thing with if you don't follow the
principle that the legislature needs to
Define what an adequate education is
you're leaving that open who's going to
do that the Department of Education
maybe are they going to change next year
and have a completely different Outlook
just giving a lot there's a lot of
opening there for constitutional rights
to be really violated here and um just
to also we disagree very strongly with
attorney ardinger um interpretation that
Claremont and that approach says the
funding has to be the same everywhere
and you can't Target or vary it that
does not say that it says that whatever
the state defines his adequacy it must
fund which is where we come in with this
first and last all everything of
adequacy is the state's responsibility
that doesn't mean adequacy is the same
everywhere if you're a place with a lot
of low-income students I'm thinking of
Berlin it's probably half free and
reduced price lunch students you have
more needs than another town where no
one's in poverty same thing if you have
a lot of English language Learners the
cost of adequacy for your District or if
you have a lot of special needs students
is higher than another District the
state still has to fund it but it
doesn't have to be the same you can
Target Aid and you should but if you're
going to Target Aid you should still be
meeting the whole constitutional
obligation of Claremont and londondary
that you are funding all of adequacy
that's said I'll take any questions if
there are thank you very much are there
any
questions yes represent Miler and thank
you for your
testimony thank you for being here so
I'd like to have you go back and your
last statement that you said about
targeting Aid um because one of the
issues we have is that current ly it's
one siiz fits all you know currently
$4,100 everybody gets the same with the
exception of free and reduced Etc but
the basic Aid is one siiz fits-all uh is
it your testimony that within the
construct that you're talking about that
some school districts can in fact
receive more Aid than others based upon
the demographics of that particular
School
District yes I think you're asking can
the formula vary based on different
demographics with how much Aid they
receive so in addition to differentiated
Aid is that what you're asking I'm I'm
I'm I'm talking about just basic state
aid can can districts receive on that
basic state aid different funding based
upon the demographics sociometrics
whatever you want to call it of that
school district so that those districts
that have greater need in fact can get
additional funding ra above and beyond
the basic identified funding adequacy
they could yes there's no reason why
they couldn't I think the way the
legislature currently does it with the
base Aid and the specific differentiated
Aid categories per student is one way to
do it you could add on other
differentials looking at the
demographics or some other
characteristic of the district that
increases its needs and fund it that way
that could be part of the formula
there's no reason it couldn't be thank
you further
questions not hearing it we have one
shean All right so I'm the last one
between you and lunch so I will be quick
uh Zach Sheen School bill that has not
gotten as much attention that I wanted
to just highlight because I think that
it is a critical element of the bill um
it's the low and moderate property tax
relief program um that is dramatically
expanded in this um legislation so I
just wanted to highlight on that single
piece um of uh what is you know a pretty
large Bill touching a lot of different
areas um so this legislation um both
reform swept in the sense that Statewide
education property tax money would then
go to the state and in part then
dramatically expands the ability of
people to access what is a currently
existing program the low and moderate
property tax relief program we currently
have that running in New Hampshire the
problem is that the um cut offs to apply
for and be eligible for it are so low
that so few people actually apply and
those that are are eligible and those
that are eligible that do apply get so
little relief that it's barely worth
their time um just in the past um year
the amount given out in property tax
relief was about $1.4
million might seem like a um well it's
not a it's not not a lot compared to the
amount of money actually um people are
actually paying property taxes that came
to about
$250 per claim on average I don't know
how many people in the state are paying
property tax bills that are only $250
but I don't imagine very many and so
what this program would do would expand
those limits so that more people would
be eligible to be more in line with
current property values inflation the
amount of money people actually need in
that property tax relief uh and it's a
really critical part of this bill as
we're talking about the heavy Reliance
on property taxes to fund our Public
Schools this would help make more people
have access to that property tax relief
um and one other piece on that there's a
question earlier about um is this bill
mandating property tax relief uh no my
understanding is is it is expanding the
eligibility so more people can apply for
it and if they do apply then the bill
lays out how you would calculate um the
the benefits that they would get for
that property tax relief um and then the
last piece is I just want to um urge the
uh committee members and the
subcommittee members sitting the
audience um to approach all of these
bills with not a uh not as a mutually
exclusive approach so not one bill at
the detriment of others or one approach
at the detriment of others all the bills
we've heard so far today have pieces
that would benefit could benefit um both
both property taxpayers and students in
New Hampshire and you have the ability
to amend them combine them tweak them
put work into them to make sure they are
working in the ways that would most
benefit you know the communities and
school districts that have the highest
need so I just would really encourage
you all to do that and be happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee not see any thank you very
much Zach with that I'm going to close
the hearing on 1686 and we'll come back
in a half hour to start start up the
next
okay
okay yeah there is
yeah it is there's a lot of they can go
into the thinking process and how we go
directions but I think we were
discussing and things s of the latter
part here well you know since your bill
more
e
open up 1675 this is relative to
adjusting education adequacy grants
based on pupil proficiency and I welcome
the prime sponsor of that bill uh
represent
leus thank you Alicia leus Hillsboro
um this bill I want to start with say
is not intended to take any money away
from anybody I don't want anybody to
lose any money because of this bill what
I want is for our students to become
proficient what I want is to incentivize
schools to focus on reading and writing
and math in the younger grades the tools
that they are going to need to be
successful in the older grades the tools
successful in
life I'm not asking teachers to work any
harder than they are I'm asking teachers
to work differently than they are I'm
asking school
systems to change their
priorities um to not spend so much
time
on things like Dei and more time on
things like reading
um I'm asking schools to
not use methods which are
ineffective I'm asking for schools to
use reading methods as were represented
by um Vice chair
cordelli so not 3 queing which is
basically educated guessing which
there's been lots of evidence is not
only um ineffective but actually harmful
to a student's ability to learn how to
read I'm asking schools to actually
focus on
memorizing the
math uh multiplication tables as opposed
to just using
calculators because if you see the
results the proficiency
scores they might start out at 72 in the
lower grades but as they move up by the
time they get to 8th grade they're 39 39
students
are proficient in
math and the thing is at that point you
really need to know your math facts you
can't reduce your fractions you can't
Factor equations you can't do any of
that stuff if you don't just know cold
and believe me I know how hard that can
be for me that was a very difficult
thing we did a lot lot of flashcards
around the dinner table my brothers all
knew their math facts before I did it
was hard for me to memorize it's still
hard for me to
memorize but I had to learn them in
order to do the rest of the math and I
became a math major eventually that is
mathematics I tried a couple years ago
to incentivize schools to to improve by
giving extra money right by giving
awards for improvement and
proficiency and that got turned
down I tried last year using the
accountability that was in this bill
that we just looked at nobody even
wanted to discuss
it um somebody's
phone or buzzer or something is going
off it's okay go
so this time so I tried the carrot I
tried something neutral so I'm trying
what you might call this the stick but I
don't want anybody to have to use that
stick I want them to say oh we might
lose our funding somewhere down the road
and I do have this um phase in over a
long period of time you get a number of
years just to bring your population up
and then slowly this will phase in in
the hopes that nobody will ever fall
into this and I have given an exception
for all of those students with special
needs and as long as they're getting the
to we have about half of our students
who are not proficient
in language arts half of our students
can't even make the level three like
halfway half of our students only 20% of
our students are special needs students
so what's happening with the other
30% why are we
not um doing whatever is necessary to
make them proficient because I think
that reading and Ma well language arts
and math are the most important thing
everything else you learn hinges on it
everything
else and you can use all those subjects
I'm not saying don't teach anything else
but do it with a focus on those things
for instance when you're doing social
studies focus on reading focus on
writing papers and focus on doing it
correctly with good grammar with you
know good spelling with good sentence
structure
when doing music you can use counting
and fractions I mean what's a quarter
note right what's a 64th note those are
all things and how do you divide up that
measure into those parts into that
fraction that's right at the beginning
of the musical line three four
time
so these things can be implemented in
everything and I'm I'm asking for people
to put a focus on it so that kids can
accomplish it and I it only goes up to
8th grade by then if you have kids
proficient all the rest will be so much
easier because all the rest uses those
things and doesn't start till the end of
third grade because kids develop reading
kids
brains uh mature at different rates but
generally by the end of third
grade
most kids who can have pretty much
um and if we do proper screening Etc
starting from the beginning for both
reading and math do you have you know
issues understanding numbers Etc and we
start getting them help from the
beginning because we know that by the
accountable we may be able to find those
children who have problems and do the
proper give them the proper um Aid that
they need to become proficient because
that's that's what school is
about I
mean really the fact that we have half
of our kids aren't proficient in reading
and more than half of our kids aren't
proficient in math and yet we brag that
oh we're our state's one of the best in
the country well our country is not one
of the best in the world and we really
there's no reason for us not to be we're
well down the list compared to other
countries and that's sad so let's put a
focus where a focus belongs and get our
kids to be
proficient cuz I personally cannot think
of a reason why if a kid had does not
have a learning
disability and we are focusing on it why
every kid can't be at least
proficient in language arts and math
thank you thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee yes represent
cordelli thank you very much for
bringing this forward um a couple of
questions
um um and in section 3A lines uh 6
through 10 pretty much
um uh you're basing things on the number
of uh students found proficient in
grades 3 through eight um is that the
number of students in
either English language arts or math
being proficient or do they have to be
proficient in both in the beginning when
you're only doing partial uh reduction
it's it is both but by the time you get
to the 100% it's either you get 50% for
one and 50% for the
other for the
questions I'll repr some that because I
have one
um where that proficiency bar is set is
kind of uh up to whether the you know
the the agency the the testing agency or
or or or even the department or
sometimes proficiencies Rock by botom um
one of the things we did in the state a
while back was we are measuring growth
of students not necessarily whether they
hit the
bar but if a student comes in and for
whatever reason there might be huge
issues at home and learning is just not
a priority survival is
priority but we're seeing some
growth if you want to use percent Iles
or you know nce scores or you know
growth scale scores any of that stuff if
they're showing growth why wouldn't that
suffice for proficient or in our
Statewide assessment now we
say academic proficiency and growth is
what we're measuring kids well growth is
what you're going to have time to find
and if you have a brand new kid you have
two years to try to bring them up to
proficient
um but why is is because growth from
very little slow growth eventually
they're going to graduate they're still
not going to be
there and yeah they may have a terrible
home environment but one of the things
you can do is have after school programs
work with those kids individually I
certainly did a lot of that as a teacher
with kids who had problems and came from
trouble
backgrounds um to get my kids to be
proficient
and I think and I've seen it done with
my
granddaughter and um who came from a
difficult
situation and yet they had after
school and she thrived that helped her a
lot so we're giving schools money for
these kids who are coming from those
backgrounds we give that bump up right
that extra adequacy for that well what
is it being used for I think that's one
of the things that can be used for
working with those kids individually
having time after school I think if
we're focused on this then we will use
that money more
appropriately are there further
questions represent
Damon thank you Mr chair so I think I
need a clarification and then I also
have a
question if I understand the bill draft
in your
remarks in fiscal year TW or Academic
Year
26 if 50% of the students at a say third
grade at whatever grade level were not
proficient in
math then that school would get 26% less
funding for that 50% of kids for half
their kids am
50% were not proficient
mhm
then
30 it would be they would get
75% of that 50% 25% less per child right
for that for those that 50% that wasn't
proficient
so the overall decrease in
funding is about 12 a half
per.
yeah may I continue go ahead thank
you and then I believe in your response
a moment ago to a
question you were suggesting that these
children could be helped by more
intensive individual after school
programs prior to that
point so how
fing the after school programs starting
this
year starting this year the money the
extra money that is given what extra
money are we talking about the money for
uh the amount of free and reduced lunch
the money that we give for districts
um uh
adjusted property values Etc all that
money that we give now that that I
called are you talking about a part of
the adequacy for yeah we have the base
level and then differentiated thank you
all the differentiate all of that that's
what the this is what that should be
applied
to helping those kids who come from
those backgrounds to be successful I
don't want to see them just written off
well they're getting better well you
know they just come from a bad
background that's the point of public
education is to get those kids up but
that means we need to be using the extra
money that we're giving for those kids
kids represent Hall thank chair thank
you for taking my questions so what is
that money in your opinion what is that
money being spent on right now the ones
for the free that's a good question
nobody ever lets us know do you have no
idea I have no idea no I do not it gets
put into the general fund it gets spent
um the schol clarify for you it goes
into the operational fund yes if it's
differentiated or base adequacy it's not
targeted money right that's what I mean
yeah so but they can Target it the
school decides how that money gets spent
right that would have to be a local
decision exactly so this is to
incentivize the locals to decide to
spend that money for the kids who are
not
proficient my my my followup to where
you are rep statement then is this a
requirement that they do this no it's up
kids and you may say yeah they're trying
now but there's an awful lot of stuff
that's going on in schools that is not
trying to teach those subjects to kids
there's an awful lot of time that's
spent on other things and I would like
to see that time spent on that I I
excuse me I would like an example of
what they're spending their money on
that isn't targeted towards kids
learning to read and do math the
question not to me that's a question
what are they spending their money on
they're spending money on learning how
they're privileged no that's not
happening that is not happening no okay
we're we're not this is not the debate
Club folks we're here to hear what's
going on in front of us
here are there any other questions for
represent leus yes representa Hall so
thank you for letting me ask my question
thank you for taking my question so you
said you don't know what they're
spending money on on the differentiated
Aid yet now you're saying you do know
because it's the wrong thing yes or
no what I
know is that there is time being spent
in
classrooms on things that don't have to
do with learning to read and write and
do
math I know that there are things spent
on seal and Dei and very ious other
things
that some of which is useful a small
amount is useful but I have heard from
teachers complaining about the amount of
time that they spend
teaching um seal stuff and devoting
chunks of the morning just on that that
they F feel that they could spend
teaching kids I mean I've looked at some
of the classroom schedules of elementary
school teachers and huge chunks in the
morning spent on seal
stuff and they complain about that they
say I have to do this this is not all
school districts this it varies School
District to school district but the
amount of time that they're spending in
the morning and they have to
record how the student is doing how
their day was the day before all kinds
of stuff so one of them that I saw was
an hour and a half an hour and a half
every morning was in that schedule tell
me an hour and a half you couldn't have
yes inviting the kids finding out where
they're at I always did that I did that
even when I subbed and I had one subject
I did that with kids I didn't even know
you got to do that but an hour and a
half that's the kind of
stuff yes we have to have you know this
one's supposedly done right now but that
they're hearing so just the followup so
if they got this money you think they
would take out all that fluff that you
don't like do you think that that's that
would incentivize them to not do the
seal and the I that is my hope that the
fear of losing the money will cause them
because people do work on incentives and
we've seen it before when the state or
the federal government made um said they
would take funding or whatever for
certain things people changed their
behavior we see it that's the way that
people do that so yes my hope is that
none of this money will ever be taken
away I don't want to see the money taken
away what I hope is that schools will go
back and
re-evaluate how they're spending their
time and see if there's some way they
can spend their time more efficiently
oh yeah we got lots of
cards okay are there any further
question we do have more cards on this
particular
Bill no you've been Russ and belch you
asked questions before no no no go
ahead thank you Mr chair and thank you
rep leus for bringing us forward um so
the the idea of incentives was brought
up and the concern about if a school
were to lose this funding how then would
they recover
and be able to teach these students
which I think is a fair question but
let's let's look at the other side of
that as well and I want to ask you given
the fact that we have traditionally been
not taking away money for incentive
based items and that funding has
continued to increase anyway our schools
right now succeeding based on our
current model of paying more
money regardless of outcomes or are we
currently in a situation where we're
failing under this
model um we have been given more giving
more money since
1970 we've had decrease in population
and more per pupil spending every year
and yet our outcomes have remained
basically stable and actually they
changed the evaluation at one point you
can see they started to go down and
right about then they changed the
evaluation methods and then they were
stable again so clearly throwing more
money throwing more money throwing more
money is not bringing about the effects
that we
want so I'm just trying to use the
incentive system to try to get people to
think about how else can we do this what
else can we do what will be more
efficient what will be more effective
it's all it's just to incentivize I
tried other means nobody wanted them I'm
trying this one probably nobody will
want this one either but I want people
to start thinking is there a way
throwing more money and more money and
more money is not working what else
might work what could we do how could we
use our time how could we use the
resources we have to be more efficient
at doing the fundamental task of Reading
Writing and arithmetic on which
everything else is built because if you
can do that in today's day and age with
the inter internet and everything you
can teach yourself anything else you
want to
learn are there further
questions R's name Damon please quick
thank you Mr chair I would like to ask
the representative to bring us before or
at our executive session on this bill
specific
documentation by school
classroom where is the evidence of it's
got to be a question asking her if she
would please bring us specific
information do that in as side because
that's not a question okay I'll try to
get whatever I can unfortunately I have
a problem with teachers being afraid of
being um penalized for speaking against
the system so I'll see what I can do are
there any further questions of represent
leus thank you very much we will go to
the next person I have on 1675 Doug
Hall
thank you Mr chairman I um Doug Hall I'm
here representing myself but uh I don't
know many of you so I've put in here a
little of my background I I chaired
house Finance subcommittee on school
funding back in the augenblick years
before the Claremont du decision um and
I was responsible for making sure that
we were trying to comply with that
formula which we never
did um as the founder of the New
Hampshire Center for Public Policy
studies and in that role U authored many
reports on student achievement in this
State um
and one of the things we did was bring
attention to the dropout rate in New
Hampshire which at that time uh 20 years
ago was
25% of the students were not completing
high school as a result of that work
that we did analyzing that a few years
later the the age at which students
could leave high school was increased by
this legislature from 16 to 18 and it's
reduced the dropout rate so I've been
involved in this for some time and I was
in I helped uh this
legislature pass the law that set up for
the first time a student database in
this state which is what's used to
record student achievement right now I
just want to say that I I support the
sponsors goals on this bill her the
goals are are laudable we need to make
sure that all the students in the state
are achieving at a proficient level now
I'll make a comment about proficiency
but we do need to pay attention and make
sure that students
are um learning their math and their
reading and and
writing however I strongly oppose this
bill it does exactly the wrong thing to
achieve that goal first
um we know that uh student achievement
no matter how you measure it is very
highly correlated with parents education
and family
income now those are not perfect proxies
but the real correlation is to parents
commitment to their own education and
their children's
education we we don't have a measure of
that but we can use these other two
parental income
um of being one that we essentially have
through free and reduced lunch now the
reason I wanted to hand out something is
to show you a couple charts the first
chart on the first page is simply the
bell curve if you take the 165,000
students we have't public schools in New
Hampshire and you test them on whatever
you test them on you're going to get a
bell curve from high Achievers to low
Achievers and it looks something like
this there are going to be some low
Achievers some higher Achievers now the
question of proficiency however is not a
factual thing the bell curve is factual
proficiency is a level established
politically and
professionally and so on the second page
I show that vertical black bar
that's just hypothetical some State some
Community decided that's where we're
going to call anybody to the right of
that proficient anybody to the left of
it has not met it but that bar can move
in fact some states when they discovered
that not too many of their students were
doing very well in the measures they had
they simply moved it
down okay so
proficiency is a political decision what
what are you going to Define as
proficiency but the most important part
of what I want to say
is that the bell curve of students
differs depending on their
backgrounds so the third little chart I
have shows that the bell curve of
students from lower income families is
shifted to the
left that's on any set of measures you
want to use in any
country but alone State and higher
income families is shifted to the right
now what does that mean with regard to
proficiency if you look at that chart it
means there are more students in the
bell curve that's moved to the left who
are below
proficient and this
bill would take funds that the state
provides whether it's the base cost
which I interpret the bill the mean
rather than the low and um the free and
reduced lunch uh supplemental funds but
what this bill would
do is that the districts like Franklin
Claremont Winchester Stratford
haal um which have higher percentages of
students from the lower income families
the blue curve on the
left would end up losing money much more
money than districts like Hanover Oyster
River Windom which are have a bell curve
to the right
so State policy currently recognizes the
need for extra
money for disadvantaged students
including those who are from lowincome
families and it's not a lot but it's
there in the in the distribution formula
but this bill if enacted would do the
exact opposite it would remove money
from the districts where there is the
most need for
improvement and that's the reason that I
strongly oppose this bill but not the
goals of the sponsors thank you very
much Mr Hall are there question
represent
Pell yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you very much for taking my question and
for being here
um I think what I'm hearing you say is
that if we continue to fund education
the way we've always funded
education that districts like clar
Franklin Claremont Winchester and
straford will probably continue to stay
in the category of lower
Achievers do you suppose it's possible
that if we tried a different method of
Education funding we might get a
different
outcome
uh yes I do think so um
and the question
is how you go about doing that um it's
it's clear to me from my experience with
this
that we have districts that cannot
afford to spend funds because they
property taxes that their uh homeowners
and business owners have to pay are so
high so there's a need for additional
funds not reduced funds in those
communities yet uh earlier this morning
there was testimony about Pittsfield
where they don't have any foreign
language teachers now that's not eighth
grade that's above that but um and the
only way that we're going to
improve the achievement of students no
matter what they're family income is is
to pay attention to how we're doing it I
think that's one of the things the
sponsor was talking about but removing
funds from the very districts that most
have the most students in need in
special need um just makes no sense to
me represent
cordelli uh thank you just to follow on
to that question um on that last chart
that you showed um you have the lower
income families and the higher income
families uh how would a different method
of
funding um impact that chart when you're
talking about
families um rather than uh school
funding or um you know anything else I'm
not sure the um correlation between um
different funding and this chart this
there a lot of ways I'll just use one if
you have um a lot of students who are
starting off um behind other students
you need to pay attention to them you
need to have lower class sizes if you
have more lowincome
students okay so if one way that you
begin to pay attention to that is well I
know the the state stat statute sets um
2025 students uh 2530 students as uh the
maximum for class size but if you if you
have a larger number of lowincome
students um students whose parents never
completed High School you're going to
need to pay more attention to them one
way not the only way is to have lower
further further questions repent
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here um I just wanted to get a
little clarification because you
described the bell curve as related to
the variable of family income and
student
performance um given that our current
funding formula uh emphasizes low income
through our free uh student launch
formula and directs more funding to
places with lower more lower income
families um does that are you suggesting
with that that belt curve that it
doesn't matter how much funding is
directed to them by the state that
they're always going to be lower
Achievers because of their family
income I don't think they will always be
lower Achievers because of their family
income no and and also remember that the
bell curve even within the
if you will segregated segregated group
of low-income families has high
Achievers it just has fewer of them it's
still a bell curve but no I think that
you can move the bell curve with the
right kinds of investment in the schools
in in the education of those students so
you know the an appropriate goal and I
think I share it with the sponsor of the
bill is if if that blue curve could be
shifted over and be the same as the red
curve on that chart we've done something
that would be very helpful I think we
would share that goal so the question is
how to do it I think there are ways to
do it but it requires money as I said
smaller class sizes
help further questions representative
pet now thank you Mr chair and thank you
again for taking my question there's a
phrase that necessity is the mother of
invention do you suppose it's possible
that if we use a different funding
mechanis ISM Educators might find a
different way an Innovative approach to
educating and all of a sudden these
lower income families start doing better
because there's been some innovation in
their education I think that's possible
um I maybe I'll just answer another um a
part of the question about how would you
um if we had a Statewide teachers
contract we would not have have
districts that can't hire teachers
because their salaries are so
low so if you want to talk about
possible policies that might help with
the situation State one single Statewide
teachers contract so the teachers get
paid the same amount no matter which
district they're working in would be a
possibility that's just a personal point
it's a dream isn't
it any anything for Mr holl further
Coral thank you Carissa Coro uh Penacook
and um I thought about which where I
should Testify the last bill or this one
um only because my uh testimony is about
outcomes and thinking about the
assumption that that the tests or the
assessment the tools are good good tools
to measure what students know it can do
when my brother went to when he was
going to first grade 1987 my mother
brought him to the test that we all had
to do and um the decision on the test if
you're going to go to first grade or you
going to go to Readiness um and so he
went into the test he knew how to count
to 20 he knew his colors his alphabet
all of those things and um when he came
out of the test I told my mother that
they were recommending him for Readiness
and my mother was a young mother and so
she just you know okay they they know
best but she got in the car and she said
Billy why did they say you didn't know
your colors and your numbers and your
letters and he said well they're adults
they asked me what color is the sky I
said purple color is the grass I said
yellow they are adults they asked me
stupid questions I gave them stupid
answers and so um in my work in talking
about assessment with teachers and
having them rethink assessment um I use
that example because we can only assess
what students are willing to share share
with us that they know and can do and so
for younger students on standardized
tests they might be willing to show up
so if they can access the test and they
can um fill out the bubbles and and do
all that stuff and they're willing to
right maybe we can understand what they
know and can do but as students get
older and they're more rebellious and
the test is not meaningful to them they
are not as willing to partic participate
in this extractive game of standardized
tests and so there are more meaningful
ways that we can assess student
understanding based on what they can do
um the tests mul I I don't have my my
own children take standardized tests I
tell the teachers I trust your judgment
on whether my student can read and on
what level based on your professional
judgment those tests are not connected
to my students assessment is human work
um and we need to remember that these
tests are based on psychometric Theory
and not the very um human work of
Education in terms of students telling
us what they know and can do based on
their individual experiences and
skills thank you very much other
questions from the committee not seeing
deer
good afternoon again for the third time
members of the education committee and
chairman lad my name is Michaela Deiter
and although I do sit on the Dober
School Board as I mentioned earlier in
the following comments I'm going to be
speaking just for myself in fact I
wasn't planning on coming up here and
speaking on this bill but after hearing
it be introduced I decided to um add my
comments I apologize for that reason I
don't have any written comments to
submit to you but I'm happy to submit
them online
afterward I've listened to this bill's
sponsor list her ideals for the outcome
of her proposed Bill hb1
1675 I heard her say she does not want
to or intend to cause school districts
to lose funding rather she hopes this
stick as she described it would
incentivize and Inspire districts to
begin educating their students in a way
that results in for some underperforming
districts drastic increases in academic
proficiency we know that students with
specific designations historically
underperform on state tests indeed our
current funding model acknowledges this
by offering differentiated aid for
students who are English language
Learners or who come from economically
disadvantaged home situations we know
this is also true for students with
established special education plans this
bill creates an allowance for students
with disabilities to be exempt from this
financial penalty for
underperformance it is both uneven and
inequitable to exempt special education
students without also acknowledging that
students living in poverty or who may be
new Americans learning a new language
experience similar academic
challenges to be clear I strongly oppose
this proposed legislation financially
punishing districts and thereby the
students they serve because some
students do not achieve high enough
scores is not a Funding Solution that
will serve our schools our students or
our state expecting schools to do a
better job educating students while
simultaneously reducing state aid defies
all logic as we have heard so many times
already today the state has a
constitutional responsibility to
adequately educate its students I have
heard no substantiation offered today
for why reducing funding to our most
needy students would somehow Inspire
them and their school districts to
achieve more this bill's primary sponsor
has spoken about her desire to increase
math Proficiency in schools based on her
love for and education in mathematics I
submit to you today that in the matter
of providing an adequate education to
New Hampshire Public School students her
math does not add up thank you very much
thank you any questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
Trumble
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David Trumble from the
town aware I oppose this bill for a
couple reasons first I think it's based
on the false notion that schools are
like private companies that operate on a
playing field that's level that all
schools are level all families are level
all educational opportunities and
systems are level and that's just not
the reality you've heard testimony that
children from low-income families have
lower educational outcomes and we have
to push that bell curve over but that is
a reality that we deal with the 2020
Commission in its executive summary has
a chart I urge you to look at it and
it's just based on free and reduced
lunch and it shows you that as your
income drops your scores drop and it's
just clear as can be that has to be
dealt with this bill would punish those
children rather than give them the help
they need the other way in which this uh
manifests itself is in the tax base
towns that don't have adequate tax bases
are not able to provide the same level
of Education as others and that's why
they can't pay their teachers as much
that's why they can't afford reading
Specialists the very things that the the
sponsor of this bill wants those
children under this system right this
bill will lose funding if you go to the
doa's website of proficiencies it's got
all kinds of data but you can look at
the Town level for every town for math
and reading I urge you to do that pick a
property poor town anyone you want and
then pick a property rich town that
adjoins it and what you'll see is that
in the property poort Town there's a lot
of children in who are in levels one and
two and not that many in level four but
the property Rich toown the inverse is
true there'll be loads of children in
level three and four and not many in
level one and two they have basically
the same educational philosophies they
just don't have the same resources so
what this bill is going to do is punish
the towns that don't have a property tax
tax base and give them even less money
and the year after that even less money
to the point where they won't be able to
even keep their schools open the goal of
increasing education is great this bill
is just going to punish the people who
need the education the most the other
problem with this bill is it assumes
that schools are not operating
rationally right now that teachers don't
go into school every day and think how
can I help this child they like I said
earlier today I'm married to a teacher
every night she works in until late
that's and there's other people emailing
back to her the other teachers they're
all working long long hours because they
care about their children they know that
the kids are coming in with a lot of
issues these days they're trying to
compensate for that and work hard for
those kids they take a English class or
a social studies class and they work
reading into it they if they have charts
they work a little math into it they do
all that when they have a child who has
extra special needs they try to make
extra efforts and figure out how can I
solve this or how can I help this child
moving along the Assumption of this bill
is that the teachers either don't care
or just aren't qualified and the school
systems are oblivious to this it's it's
a false story and I hope that eventually
this state stops having these false
stories and starts recognizing our
teachers for the dedicated professionals
that they are we treat them to the
respect that they deserve and then once
we agree on that then I think the rest
of the issues will move forward much
more smoothly thank you very much thank
you are there questions from the
committee yes representative Pell thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming in
and taking my question you're welcome
have you ever seen any statistics or
data um that demonstrates how
children um say in a Regional School
District um from surrounding towns that
may have a lower or may have a higher
incidents of free and reduced meal
students perform when they attend a
school that is in a town where the
property values are higher so say you
have you know students from surrounding
towns in elementary schools and then
they go to a regional middle or High
School uh I I don't really know the data
on that I'm sorry but thank you for the
question further questions from the
committee representa beler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for this testimony
um I just wanted to get a little more
clarification because again we heard the
the
relationship between parental income and
student
performance and I understand that the
concept of of the bell curve and that
these are two different variables that
are being related but it's still not
clicking with me if you could explain
the causitive relationship between them
that is being suggested since parents
aren't paying out of pocket for public
school this is not something that's a
burden to their income so you're asking
are you asking thank you for the
question representative belter are you
asking why would children from families
with lower incomes have lower
educational results yes it seems to be
suggested that it was a positive factor
for lower performance but and it's being
related to in uh funding but I don't see
how it's related I don't understand the
linkage okay so first of all
representative Hall indicated that
within the bell curve you're going to
have low and high under whether it's low
income or high
income there's going to be that variable
so it's it's not we're not nobody's
saying that children who are from low
income families are not capable or don't
have you don't have children who
outperform children from high income
families it's just when you're taking
the averages he's saying the average
bell curve versus the other average bell
curve so I just want to make clear of
that um I think the other thing that
representative Hall said was that the
the the clear correlations are parents
education and also um the parents income
level I believe were the two variables
that he cited and he's says this
translates to a commitment to education
and it may not be I'm not saying that
somebody from a low-income parents
aren't committed education uh I I'm my
parents came from from very poor
backgrounds and but it it can mean
sometimes if you're from a low-income
you may not have the time to be able to
devote to your child if you're working
three jobs a week or you're a single
parent who's also working three jobs a
week or maybe you're like the stories we
heard this morning where you're being
raised by your grandparent or there's so
many different variables where low
income can be attached to other factors
it's not income that makes you not a
good achiever it's the low income brings
with it many other variables and those
variables do translate to to educational
difficulties which can be solved with
lower classroom sizes I don't have the
studies with me today I wasn't thinking
this debate was going to go on but back
under the EFA debate I brought in some
evidence there was a study quoted dozens
of studies when we spend more money
Dropout rates go down uh scores go up
attendance at colleges goes up lifetime
income goes up dramatically so spending
more money on schools does work and it's
especially effective in lowincome school
districts and there was a great study
from Texas that came out on that very
point just
recently I me just a real quick one
because I I I think I understand the
linkage better now thank you for that
explanation yes but seeing that we
already do at the state level send extra
money for the poverty indicator of free
and reduced lunch how much more are you
suggesting that we need to spend to
equalize that outcome so the extra
amount for free and reduced lunch is I
think $2,000 or something on that range
but when you look at the overall
statistics the average school spends
20,000 there are schools that can only
afford to spend 13 or 14,000 per per
student so we have a big Gap to make up
it's it's it's huge and if they need
extra money instead of having five or
6,000 less per student in that town
they're the the ones that probably need
2,000 even more than the average so it
it
gets as a state we have looking with
pride at our educational system but we
have a blind eye for the fact that the
property Rich towns can provide great
schools and they keep those great
teachers our property poor towns can't
do that and that's the problem and so
all the solutions have got to be focused
on those towns but taking money away
from them because they fail is going to
cause the exact opposite result that we
want you're
welcome any further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman and we have one more red
pink card on on
1675 uh Zach
Shen interested time I'll my testimony
because speakers have thank you the
point thank you very much so with that
1555 welcome representative HS well I'm
just trying to get to your
bill so go ahead um I'm introducing
1555 um this is uh from the batch of
bills that I receive that um I'm doing
because the Department of Education
asked for them this is number three and
I hope you'll dispatch it the same way
you did the first two um it's it's very
simple um it has to do with uh I'll let
um Mark explain the details of it but I
listened to what he had to say and
essentially um he's asking that when it
comes to an existing provision that
allows the school districts to change
their
budget that the Department of
Education is the one who will explain to
them what the limits are about how much
how much they can add or how much um
they can subtract because they don't
always get it right so thank you so we
we're going to have Mark next so if
anybody has questions let's ask Mark
Magan magella I I deal deal with them
often times but you know I always have
trouble stumbling on his
mark
for the record Mark manganello
Department of Education Bureau of school
Finance um so I think this bill or this
concept is maybe simple to someone like
representative fellow who did my job
before me for for several multiple
decades um so for it's a little inside
baseball so I'm just going to walk you
through a hyal uh hypothetical district
and how current law works and what this
bill is trying to change so for example
if we use havil as a hypothetical
District havil received an adequacy
estimate of State revenues on November
15th from the Department for fiscal year
25 as they were working on this fall and
winter on their fiscal year 25 budget
they received a number let's say that
number is 500,000 in adequacy
Revenue um now they're going to adopt um
if they if they pass it adopt a budget
in the spring of 24 that's going to be
the fiscal year 25 budget
then what all of you could do the
legislature is you could change fiscal
year 25 adequacy through an change in
law and so you could say we want to give
all districts an extra x amount of money
based on whatever and so let's say you
Chang the law and you in change the 25
formula after they've passed their
budget now when they were building their
budget they thought they were going to
get
500,000 now you've changed the law and
now let's say they're going to get
600,000
so um they've already passed a budget
and they didn't know that they were
going to get this extra
$100,000 so there's a provision in
current law that says okay you passed
your budget but state law changed and
now you have an extra 100,000 so RSA
1973a says you already did your normal
annual town meeting now you can do a
special district meeting and so where
the confusion comes into play is I gave
say hey rolls the school district I said
you're getting $500,000 and I said that
in November 15th they built their budget
off that $500,000 number now let's say
new data comes in the State Law changes
and I say now you're getting
$600,000 so I want to use the provision
hail is probably thinking maybe I want
to use the provisions of RSA 1973a to
increase my budget because I didn't know
that money was going to come in and so
they might go well I can make a warrant
article for $100,000 because that's how
much additional money I've received but
that's not how current law Works um the
way way current law works is I have to
tell all the districts that state law
has now
changed um and they are thinking they
they can see that they have an extra
$100,000 in this hypothetical but they
have to wait for me to do a second
analysis before they can determine what
the maximum War article it is they can
put on the uh uh have hearings for and
put in special district meeting and the
way I do that is I basically have to
isolate all changes in adequacy that are
due to state law um so for some
communities it could be so basically in
the hypothetical um what I end up doing
is I end up taking the current latest
data and I run it through the old
formula and I run it through the new
formula and I come up with the variance
and so it might not be $100,000 it might
be $80,000 it might be
$120,000 and so districts are trying to
run special district meeting but I'm
holding them up a little bit because
they're waiting for a two spreadsheets
one that says what they're really going
to get in reality and then they're also
waiting on a spreadsheet for me which
has this sort of hypothetical reality is
if isolated only changes in state law to
the adequacy formula and um a lot of
districts get it because I spend a lot
of time educating them on what they have
to do with their warrant articles but in
the past um I believe it's happened once
at least um in memory Dr has had to deny
a warrn article because a district
thought that they were going to get what
we estimated versus what the actual was
they thought that was the what they
could do for a warrant article but they
exceeded what the statutory change was
and so um Dr had to kind of give a warn
article a haircut because of it um so it
creates a lot of extra work on our end
to educate them about the Nuance of the
law I have to run a second spreadsheet
of adequacy which I never like having
two competing adequacy spreadsheets out
there
um and so if we change this law and um
it's it's only changing how we determine
what their maximum warrant article may
be um it just follows a more intuitive
process which is your warrant article
will be uh maximum War article will be
the difference between what you thought
you were going to get and what you
actually got um and not this additional
calculation sorry if everyone follows
that representative Cornell you're gonna
notes Mark comes from LBA legislative
budger Assistance
Office okay are there any
questions of
mark thank you very much we'll see you
are there any other people testifying on
this
hearing okay
except uh do it in nature where we are
with our
schedule no we're going to try get
closer to schedule here um so we are now
going to open up HB 1686 there people
waiting here for this one uh this is
relative to requiring excess revenues
raised through the Statewide education
property tax to be remitted to the
education trust fund and prohibiting the
Department of Revenue Administration
from setting negative local and County
tax rates on real
property okay Prime sponsor March you're
here representative Smith welcome thank
you very much Mr chair I'm delighted to
be here before the education committee I
was a little surprised that the bill was
sent here um but glad because it's
always good to have more people familiar
with this issue I also by the way am
pleased that you worked with the speaker
to make sure that um members of uh Ways
and Means and finance would be included
in some discussions since this is
probably where that bill goes you know
when they say it's not about the money
it always is about the money always
about the dollar and yet the basic
principle here is a principle that all
of you on this committee have dealt with
and that is trying to make
sure that
um uh that that adequacy funds are uh
distributed in a way that meets
constitutional requirements I want to
point out to you that since I asked
um uh OS to draft this bill um I had
some unexpected help from uh the third
branch of government from the judicial
branch because unbeknownst to
me while I had already asked for this
bill to be drafted um uh the judge rof
ruled straight that swept is currently
administered is
unconstitutional um and that is exactly
the issue that I'm trying to address
here I come from durm and I know you all
think things are crazy in Durham and you
don't do things in hail the way you do
in Durham I understand all the time well
because you're the chair I mean I could
pick on someplace else but I mean you
know why would I it makes more sense to
deal with
power maybe it's different in havil but
in Durham you know the town doesn't pay
the taxes my town does not pay my taxes
maybe your town does in haval or
someplace else but in Durham we pay the
citizens pay the taxes and for reasons
that I could discuss with you from an
historical perspective because I was
here when this
happened um
the state
tax was
collected by the town or the city or
however you want to do that and they got
to keep the float not only that they
actually got new computers and all kinds
of things all of that in return for them
acting as agents for the um for the
state but what has happened is the money
that is the Statewide educational
property tax is supposed to be used for
education and it's supposed to be
allocated according to the formula that
we in our wisdom or lack thereof have
established and there are towns and you
can see it in in the bill back of the
bill we actually have a timely fiscal
note which is really good you could see
that there are a number of towns that
have received more
money than they need under the formulas
we
established to meet the
educational uh expenditures of their
community and what has been happening is
towns have used that money for anything
else that they feel like it but it's not
their money it's the citizens money the
citizens were paying the tax or in some
cases a Dr has actually constructed
something that I have a hard time
understanding
but you know who am I where they have a
negative
rate now if you could figure out that
negative rate you're better than I am um
and I'm be glad to hear from it what
this bill attempts to do is make
Fair the
utilization of the educate of the
Statewide educational property tax and
in those
jurisdictions where they're not they
don't use that
money for educational adequacy as we
have decided that money should go back
into the state coffers now you have to
understand that it's already been
figured that it's in the state coffers
because that was how much money was
raised by the Statewide educational
property tax
this is just saying that when it gets
expended it gets expended in the right
way um it's not terribly complicated I
was delighted that the judge supported
this um argument there was a case that
had been brought and made these points
and the judge agreed with it um but now
the bill is here and um I I urge you to
take this as one of the easy ones that
you're going to have to deal with
in the Myriad education bills that you
have before you and uh just kind of do a
little accounting correction here and I
thank you very much for the time to
present the argument thank you very much
representative Smith uh represent
Cornell you have a question yes thank
you very much representative Smith being
here um just wondering what do you
expect uh the impact to be
in those towns that have an excess swept
that is now being returned to the state
I would expect that the money that
doesn't really belong to the town
because it's our money and it was raised
to meet Statewide expenses because don't
you this is not the local education tax
this is the state education tax that
that money will go back into the pot and
be used for the purpose is that we in
the legislature have said it should be
used for um you know if I wanted to
really give an
example and I didn't want
it to offend the um the chair I would
say molten Boro I mean we can all think
of people we know or know of who have
incredibly wonderful terrific valuable
expensive
spreads in molten Boro and I kind of
don't think that you or I should have
the
responsibility of saving
them uh from having to invest in
educating children in this state and
that's what's going on now all I'm
saying is just level the planing
field thank you yes follow up yes thank
you
um but I used to represent molten buror
oh if I had only known that I would have
picked another town that's okay I'll
pick on I'll pick on my own towns um if
you look at uh for instance My Town
Tuftonboro if you look at the medium
median income in Tuftonboro it is in the
middle of the pack and I think wolfboro
is even lower in terms of the median
family income so you know if you're
saying that um these are rich
communities um I don't think that the
facts behold that
argument I absolutely on this issue
alone representative cardelli I agree
with you not 99% but 100% I think you're
absolutely right and that is exactly my
point this isn't the money that has uh
that we should be spending to make it
possible for people at the lowest end of
the income scale to have access to the
same quality education we want everybody
else to have that's not what this money
is this money came from individuals
paying their taxes supposedly for the
Statewide education property tax the
money should go to the state if it's not
being used by those towns that have
banked it um to meet educational needs
and some of that money representative
cordelli might in the long run be able
to be used to address the needs of those
uh
individuals um who are in
schools which need a little extra help
because of the limited income
of their
residents thank you but that don't bite
yeah I'm not representative
Miler thank you Mr Mr chair and thank
you representative Smith for being here
now you you are a veteran legislator
here and so I want to ask you a
historical
question uh originally the swep was
created out of a state out of a decision
made by the um by the Supreme Court
dealing with school funding and it's my
understanding that it was collected
basically as you're saying here that it
was remitted all the state swept money
was remitted
to the Dr at one point in time and then
as I understand it in 2011 or so it
stopped can you give us a a
would I have
Theory and I have some facts to back it
up um but the facts that I have to back
up would involve my pointing fingers 10
or 15 years after the fact at certain
institutions in this state that saw a
good
thing and um I don't think that's going
to help any of us in trying to deal
today with the problems that we're
facing so um perhaps we could have a cup
of tea privately um uh representative
Mila but for now I would just say that
trying to address the problems of
meeting the educational needs of our
children going back to the initial
decision when we didn't accept well we
accepted the alic formula except for one
little thing we didn't fund it and since
then decision after decision after a
decision has been made sometimes
shortsighted sometimes
meeting needs of one group or another
but I think we
now particularly because of the courts
but not only because of the courts um I
think we now have an opportunity to see
if we can get us closer to the perfect
more perfect union okay it's a followup
please so you you will confirm though
that up until
2011 the swept was in fact a Statewide
tax collected remitted to Dr and at on
2011 that system stopped I corre believe
I believe that that is so and I know
that there are people behind me who know
much more about it than I do thank
you but that date is
accurate
2011 uh any further questions of the
representative
represent
belard thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing us forward um so I'm
following the the base Logic the idea
that a a state tax should not
necessarily be utilized to offset local
um non-education items makees some
sense I'm not sure the solution that is
in here makes quite as much sense I'm
hoping you can talk me through it so
we're saying that if schools or rather
local uh districts their towns don't um
utilize this toward their schools then
it will be remitted to the state coffers
at which point it can be redistributed
to places that may it may need it more
but I think the question is do we really
expect that if we tell towns use it or
lose it they're actually not going to
use it and we're going to have money
flowing back to the state from
this well I don't think that's it I hear
what you're saying um I of course always
believe that all are going to try to do
the right thing always maybe it doesn't
always happen that way but that's what I
think but here what we're talking about
is uh formulas that we establish here
right here dollar amounts that we
establish right here where we say to
education
if they're not using it for
education for any number of reasons
including that they don't need it
because they have unlike
Durham um they have a a tax rate that
makes it easier for them to manage these
things um they're not supporting a
university for example
um that money should go back to where it
belongs go right back
into the
bank and then go out
for purposes that are specified and um I
think that's something that's just
common
sense um maybe I'm
naive I probably am
naive you're being
streamed any further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
very much I appreciate your
consideration of this bill and um I hope
you will see your way clear to saying
absolutely thank you thank you Mr yeah
Coto thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon good afternoon afternoon
committee members my my name is Mark
takoto and I'm currently the the chair
of Coalition communities 2.0 which is a
group of 27 cities and towns that have
come together to ensure that any future
Funding Solution for state aid to
education does not unfairly pit one
municipality against others by mandating
that tax money raised in one
municipality be sent to another town to
be
appropriated on behalf of the 27
municipalities who are members of our
Coalition this is why I appear before
you to oppose House Bill
1686 this bill is an unfair solution to
fund education that has been tried
before treating similarly situated
communities differently will not be well
received in our communities throughout
the state and will be difficult ult to
sustain we have seen this disruptive
approach some 20 years ago when
so-called donor towns were first created
fortunately the problems raised by that
original funding system were legislated
away uh as we just talked about 11 uh in
20 uh
2011 the policy flaws in this bill
mirror the recent State Superior Court
decision issued in November that sends
the state of New Hampshire Back to the
Future that decision which is pending
appeal in the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and this bill creates winners and
losers all across the granite state and
because there are many variables in the
calculation the system that creates
these winners and losers can change a
community from one side to the other on
a year-to-year
basis this errant decision and this bill
would authorize the State of New
Hampshire to take tax money paid by
taxpayers in one town and give it to
other towns to spend without any
accountability to those who paid the
taxes that is fundamentally wrong and at
odds with how New Hampshire cities and
towns have governed themselves for
centuries House Bill 1686 creates an
unfair
redistribution of property tax revenue
this failed policy has been tried before
and repealed it did nothing but cause
acrimony between our municipalities and
help to initiate more wrongheaded
lawsuits there is no inherent fairness
accountability or fiscal responsibility
in this bill Coalition communities 2.0
appreciates the challenges in addressing
school funding in our state we care
deeply about ensuring a quality
education for our children and we will
continue our advocacy for a fair and
comprehensive approach to education
funding in New Hampshire working with
legislators Community leaders and the
general public our members are confident
that an appropriate resolution can be
developed that does not treat
neighboring towns disproportionately or
differently thank you Mr chairman I'll
be happy to try and address any question
questions that you or the members of the
committee may have thank you are there
questions from the committee represent
Luna sure thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you very much Mr DDO for
joining us this afternoon um you
mentioned a bunch of stuff in your in
your in your testimony but there's one
item I'd like to ask you about when you
said you're committed to uh to working
to
find a fair and comprehensive approach
to funding Public Schools
um could you tell us a little bit more
about what's behind that commitment and
um and how do we know that that
commitment is um is
reached the the commitment is to find
ways uh to utilize State resources not
local property taxes um the the fact of
the formula that we use can actually
change communities from donor
communities to receiver communities year
to year as I said um our commitment is
to just try to find ways to utilize
other state resources to do this and a
followup and so so success would be
finding a solution not sorry there's no
good Solutions Left Right corre would be
finding a solution yes right thank you
correct further
questions
I don't see any hands thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
Hall U Mr chairman I have a a copies
again a couple tables in
here so it's helpful if members
can see those because I'm going to refer
to
them thank you Mr chairman um I'm here
as a private citizen uh but somebody
who's been deeply involved in school of
finances I've explained before uh here
to support House Bill
1686 and in my testimony I'd like to
just go through this the bill the
language in the bill uh prohibits the
setting of negative quote local
education or County tax rates there's
some Ang ambiguity in that term local
because the Department of Revenue
Administration which sets the rates uses
the term local only with local education
they use the term Municipal for
municipal tax rates town and city tax
rates as long as Dr interprets the
Bill's word local to include Municipal
as well as local education tax rates
then the Bill's okay but if ER
interprets local to mean only local
education then the bill needs to be
amended to add municiple that's my first
point second point on page two of the
Bill's fiscal note and so I sort of
direct you there but Dr states that the
bill would quote result in an
indeterminable increase in Revenue to
the state ETF the education trust
fund
Dr does not
understand that the full amount of the
Statewide education property tax swep
the full
amount is already included in the
education trust funds revenue and the uh
the second table the third page of my
testimony shows this this document on
the third page is from page
150 of the annual comprehensive
financial
report audited for the last state fiscal
year
2023 and I've noted on the top this
chart is for the education trust fund
every year from 2014 to
2023 and in the top you'll note that in
2023 it has $63 mil
98,000 of Revenue that's the full amount
including
what Coalition communities keep that
goes beyond adequate education it's the
full
amount it's already in the education
trust fund down further about halfway
down the page you'll see under
Appropriations the adequate education
grant to
which is the money from the swept is
identically equal to the amount of the
revenue so the state books contrary to
what Dr says in the fiscal note already
include the revenue and the
expenses and here's the final point
about
this that 263 million or in the prior
years the 363 million is being paid out
from the education trust fund if you go
to my last
page this is the text of RSA
19839 that defines what monies can be
spent from the education trust
fund monies and such funds shall not be
used for any purpose other than and then
there are 14 purposes the first
one to distribute adequate education
grants to
municipalities and school districts
pursuant to RSA 19842 what that means is
that's the adequacy amount so the
education trust fund can
legally send back if you will I'm not
talking about where the cash goes but in
the bookkeeping to the to all the
communities the amount they paid for
adequacy the amount that the Coalition
communities get that goes beyond
adequacy there's no Authority for it
being spent here in RSA
9839 so all these
years the state has not been complying
with
19839 now I'll go back to the question
of
the negative tax rates which
a lot of people have no idea even
happened but it's been going on for
decades so the second page the table on
my second
page is these unincorporated
locations that have been awarded
negative tax rates for years and the
negative tax rates I've shown here in
Red so took me a little extra time to
get a color printer to do it but
nevertheless I wanted to make make sure
you could see negative tax rates so I
just want to point out one thing I'll
use an example go down to
dicksville dicksville notch
okay there is $31 million of property in
dixville now the bossoms is one big
piece of that okay and if you look they
have a negative Municipal rate of
$33 which offsets the county rate of
$342 so that in essence those properties
in dicksville are paying only 39 cents
tax rate to the
county because they've offset it with a
negative Municipal rate the balsams is
not paying Coos County its property
tax if you go further across dicksville
you'll see
the uh State education tax
rate of 38
cents and the local education tax rate
of a negative 52
cents in total in the final right hand
column I'm showing how much money was
raised by the local education tax
actually
$16,000 was essentially sent back to
taxpayers and the taxpayers were
responsible only for 11,000 the third
column from the right $11,800 in taxes
so the properties in dixville paid
nothing for the education of any student
in the Hampshire under
swept not only that but they also didn't
pay Coos County this is the craziness of
the way swept is being administered and
it's the reason in addition to the fact
the court found the same thing that I'm
here supporting this Bill thank you
thank you very much are there questions
Hall thank you for the sheets you
provided
fellows welcome
representative thank you so now I'll
tell you a different version
of history as I remember it um just to
address some of the things that that
have been said um it it is true
that um that for a short time that towns
did remit excess to the state and my
recollection of it was it is that it was
only for a couple of years and I'm
positive that that ended way before 2011
like it might have been um 2005 or six
something like that also I can tell you
that
um it may have been connected to the to
the uh I don't recall exactly why it
stopped being sent in what I do remember
is that there was an RSA adopted I think
it was something within something that
Senator gatsis had in a bill related to
school funding and what it said is that
any excess had to be spent on
education so that meant it could be
funding the um school budget obviously
we all know adequate education Aid has
never covered the full cost of a of
educating the students in any District
so that money that excess could be spent
on
local part of the school budget I mean
that's all there is to it so and um that
statute I don't think it's in there
anymore at some point it got it got U
repealed and so I think it probably got
repealed
sometime
after 2017 because that's when I stopped
working in the at the Department of
Education but my original testimony
was going to go over the history a
little bit and um just to say that and I
can give you some of this in writing
when I can go upstairs and get a copy of
it that U 25 years ago the Supreme Court
ruled that the state needed to
significantly increase funding to school
districts the state quickly put together
a new funding plan that on paper showed
a significant increase part of that
increase was simply to take each Town's
property tax assessment for schools and
break it into two pieces one piece
remained labeled as a local school
property tax and the new piece was
labeled State education tax the total
property taxations for those school
districts did not change at all they're
to the bottom line of their tax bill
this part this action did not Chang the
bottom line of their tax bill no new
Revenue was raised from property taxes
because the sum of these two pieces were
the
same so SE swep has
been simply a mechanism it it was
developed simply as a mechanism to
reduce the amount of real cash payments
to school districts so it looks on looks
on paper is if the state is paying or
you know over $300 million more of the
cost of Education when in fact it's
really the property taxpayers that were
initially paying that money and are
still paying that money of the one
exception being to these these really
tiny places the ones that have no
students at all which I that applies to
everything I say so I'm just not going
to keep saying over and over
again so I want you to keep in mind what
was the original intent when you're
considering what you want to do with
this bill and also I hope that you will
remember that there are rich and poor
people living in every single town and
property tax there are rich and poor
property tax payers and there are and as
we hear every day there are people who
can't afford to buy a home and they and
they can't afford to buy their pay their
property taxes prot particularly if
they're seniors and they're living in
these homes that they paid off the
mortgage a long time ago and now they're
property tax bill has been gone has gone
up because it's been reassessed and
shifted with the reassessment shouldn't
hypothetically increase tax bills but
when it's shifted between different
components of property for example um
businesses during covid nobody wanted to
buy buildings that that were for retail
or for for um con you know um for
businesses people didn't want to make
more buy more office space it made the
home values go up so one class of
property the pro the value goes down the
second another class goes up so you know
it's
property tax
is um not very well connected to the
ability of who pays it and their their
financial um ability to pay those
taxes I also want to tell you so that's
my my um speech in terms of
purpose and now I just wanted to go over
some of the technical issues so what I
would tell you about the negative tax
rate is that you really can't get rid of
that and and frankly you shouldn't be
very concerned about that there are
reasons other than education that you
could have a negative tax rate um one of
the things could happen in a really
small town and I've seen this happen is
that they um they have a a lot of forest
land and when it's cut they have to pay
a Timber tax to the town and if it's a
really tiny town you know with just
part-time people you know the the town
office is only open one day a week that
that Revenue coming in could be more
than what their budget is for the
municipality and all it can also happen
with education tax because we have some
some places that have they only have one
student went worse location for example
had might have one student this year and
then the next year they don't have a
student and adequacy Aid as you know
isn't paid on the students the adequacy
aid that's being paid up for this school
year isn't the money for the students
this school year it's the money based on
the students that you had last year so
if you have no student this year and you
did have a student last year that money
can come into your school budget
hypothetically the budget could be zero
because you knew you weren't going to
have any students that gives you a
negative tax rate because because the
revenue coming in is more than the
expenditures going up that's all
negative tax rate is from my perspective
Dr they they look at it just from a
think uh let's
see another another issue
that comes up with this bill has to do
with
timing so you could
have um a district that didn't think
they were going to have any excess that
they had to remit back to the state
because in March they voted on their
school budget but they're not going to
find
out
until
September I not sure if I even have the
right year they're not going to find out
until um September for sure how much
adequacy that they're going to get and
if they're going to have excess or not
and so they didn't plan on having to
send that money back so that's that can
definitely create a problem for them how
how are they going to change how what
are they going to do and you heard Mark
talk talk earlier about the crunch
that he can get into
when the statute that
says districts can change their they can
have a special hearing I think it is to
change their budget but if if the
adequacy aid formula is changed so you
can have that going on at the same time
then they find out they have an exess
you really have a time crunch in ter in
terms of like how you're going to get
those property test tax bills out in the
normal time frame which is around
November let's
see I I this is my personal thought is
that if this is really a state property
tax then the state should be sending
bills to the property tax owner this is
kind of operating like the right now
like or the proposal is that the state
sends a property tax bill to the
municipality but really it's property
taxpayers that are paying that money um
so what happens when somebody doesn't
pay all their taxes on time you know
that happens every single town and
sometimes people pay part of their
property tax they can't afford the whole
thing they pay part of it that's a good
start so how are you going to figure out
how much of that is swep money that
excess that's supposed to go back to the
state and that's a problem what's been
going on historically of course we all
know that swep really that it's that
it's not a tax it it's not a tax well
let's see some people call it a virtual
tax some people call it a phantom tax I
like to call it smoke and
mirrors because the money doesn't really
go out and it doesn't really come back
come in it's just on paper and it's
always 363 million exactly the same
dollar
amount so
uh I think I'll stop
there well thank you very much
representative fellows lot of
information there uh are there any
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
something
okay good afternoon chairman lad and
members of the committee um I hope
you'll indulge me just a little bit I
want to talk briefly about this bill and
a couple others you heard earlier I'm
going to start from a a much higher up
standpoint and not get a lot into the
tax details um because that really is
not my uh area of expertise I want to
talk about constitutional rights and
obligations because this is all about
educating
students in the grite state every graned
state child has the constitutional right
to a robust public
education it is the Constitutional
obligation of the state to provide the
opport opportunity for that through
funding the public district schools so
that that can be
provided um and it is the incredibly
complex duty of you all to figure out
how to make that happen um that's not
just my opinion that is the result of
you know what written in our
Constitution and the findings of
numerous court cases over the past
several
decades we should have an equally robust
opportunity for a public
education in Franklin Claremont and
Merlin as we have in Bedford Windham and
Handover we should not have situations
where you have public high schools who
cannot
get live teachers to teach geometry and
algebra too because the pay scale is so
low and the classes are so crowded that
they have to do virtual classes with the
Community College which is you know a
great workaround solution but it's not
the same as having a live person to
teach the class we uh when you have
other high schools that have multiple
advanced placement math classes
available that's not fair to our
students it's not an equal opportunity
for a public
education so you have a huge challenge
in front of you to try and meet that so
that every student in the granite state
can get an equally robust opportunity
for that public education now there were
bills today about different approaches
and again we've had experts in here
talking about the merits of each and you
know different bill as it came up the
one we were just listening to um HB 1686
with the Statewide education property
tax we would be in favor of that bill
based on on the court ruling on the Rand
case because it
addresses the um disproportion Pate
impact the current Statewide property
tax is having on property taxpayers in
different communities that's one issue
education earlier you heard HB 1533
which would increase the per pupil as
quy Grant to
$110,000 I understand that would be a
very difficult thing to do given our
state finances but it also would go a
long way towards helping make sure that
every student gets the education they
have a constitutional right to and
that's what this really should be about
what do students need what do they
deserve because they have a
constitutional right to it we would
support that hb1 1656 would increase the
um the aid for special education
students to $27,000 when I first saw
that I was amazed but yes that is
basically accurate as an average it's
actually just a little bit under what it
costs if you average all the costs of
special education divided by the number
of students receiving special education
services and those are the costs that
can break town and District budgets so
we would be in support of HB 1656 we
understand not all of these are going to
pass they can't all be funded but what
we're really urging you to do is to work
hard on these and find a way to come
closer to meeting the state's obligation
to all of our
students and fulfilling their
constitutional right to get a robust
public education no matter which city or
town they live in in the state now is
the time to meet the constit
Constitutional Duty for fully funding
the opportunity for robust public
education for All graned State students
every student in the granite state
deserves a welcoming inclusive classroom
where they can learn grow and Thrive
with small class sizes individual
attention from a teacher learning
support from par
Educators uh the chance for experiential
learning a challenging curriculum so
they can experience the joy of learning
and the spark um you know to grow and
learn and become the best they can be so
we just really urge you to dig in and
make progress on this
for the sake of all of our students and
that's it thank you are there any
questions from committee
members I see thank you very much uh
Katherine
heck thank you chairman lad and members
of the committee I don't often have the
privilege of coming before you my name
is Katherine heck for the record and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association or the 234 cities and towns
of New Hampshire and normally we do not
get involved in education and I'm here
to be very clear that we have no
position on um a a good part of this
bill and that we don't take a position
on the swept how it's assess the excess
that is um well beyond my pay grade
however the negative tax rate that this
brings forward and not being able to
assess a negative rate um in the local
County or State education I I will Echo
representative fellow sentiments in
that we are concerned that there are
possibilities that a town could in fact
have a negative tax rate and as you see
your tax bills you're all taxpayers here
in New Hampshire there's four components
to your bill the State education which
we're not here to talk about the local
education the municipal and the county
all of those rates have different
governing bodies bringing forward those
budgets and those appr corations and the
offsetting revenues and they are all set
and calculated differently they all have
their own formula the concern is that
there could be very real reasons why a
municipal rate could need to be negative
and I would ask the committee to
entertain that of the four rates if each
were a dollar and your tax bill as a
taxpayer is a dollar right you're going
to pay that over to your town tax
collector they are responsible for
collecting all of the taxes for the
community
now if the according to this bill if the
rate for the town could not go negative
but I had some huge influx of Revenue
let's just for example say that a
benefactor left the town double the
operating budget with the sole purpose
of offsetting taxes that year so I've
getting all of this wonderful revenue
and for two years we don't have to pay
taxes and I can only go to zero you're
all paying $3 but I have that Revenue
right I have that Revenue if I can do a
negative tax rate what you would all be
paying is $2 because each of the
political subdivisions even though we
collect on behalf we perfect that system
on behalf of the county and the school
districts and we pay it over that
obligation right we we would have that
Revenue somewhere else so not only in an
accounting practice I'm not sure how we
would account for Zero versus a negative
because I'd have all of this offsetting
Revenue in this pile over here so for
the taxpayer and the taxpayer themselves
we do believe that there are very few
cases in which in negative rate is
reasonable and possible and the the tax
rate should be reflected um
appropriately because each of the
subdivisions again one doesn't offset
the other so a negative rate on the on
the county or on the municipality
doesn't offset somebody else that
obligation to that other entity based on
their budget and their revenues is still
paid over in full to them it only would
affect however the Dr sets the rate the
political subdivision
or the state although I've never seen a
swept negative tax rate um it would only
affect that one entity that one taxing
entity so it's just important to
consider that negative tax rates are
possible and there are two in fact this
year um so we would like you to
contemplate that in your all your
considerations because we want the bills
to be accurate for the taxpayer
themselves so that's all I have if you
have any questions thank you are there
any
questions not see any thank you very
much
Andrew
valinski good afternoon Andrew binsky
from East conquered for the record uh
thank you Mr chairman and uh committee
members um over decades long experience
in the state I've learned never to
disagree with representative Smith nor
to try to expand on her testimony um so
I shall avoid both and adopt her
position uh I will say I um was pleased
to hear the commitment of the Coalition
communities to finding a solution to
education funding that does not involve
a Statewide property tax and I'll be
happy to work with them when they come
out with their income or sales tax bills
in the near
future it has been
decades since we have had a Statewide
property tax and the issue of what
happens to the excess in those decades
the communities who we call wealthy
communities they call themselves
donors have never never never to my
recollection supported any methodology
publicly to resolve school funding
issues so I'm happy to learn today that
they're going to jump on board with
either income or sales tax um one point
I want to make is that with respect to
the Statewide property tax to fund
education that tax is dedicated to
funding the state's portion of Education
that we all call education
adequacy the Dr sets negative rates in
communities that do not have local
education
expenses so that the negative local
education offsets the positive Statewide
property tax which is now about A1 a.
half
th000 the idea that you only pay for
your own kids or you don't pay anything
because you don't have your own children
in schools flies in the face of the idea
that this is a state tax to support the
Statewide program of Education which is
constitutional adequacy that is what
judge ruol was getting at I am
co-counsel in the Rand case judge ruoff
granted our motions on this point about
the swept tax
and that's what we were all talking
about it's not about whether you have a
Timber tax Bonanza one one particular
year I'm not aware of anyone who's
bequeathed twice the municipal budget to
any municipality in recent history I
suppose that could happen that's not
what this is about this is about using
local education negative tax rates to
keep keep communities that don't have
local expenses from contributing to the
state's Bill and that is
unconstitutional as found by judge ruof
um the final point I would make is
collecting the money from the negative
communities connect collecting the
excess monies from the wealthy
communities results in about a 2425
million pot of
money that money can go to fund things
like representative
AMS enhanced property tax
exemption portion of
1586 or representative Ames had a
another Standalone bill that addresses
representative cordell's problem of
lowincome taxpayers who happen to live
in property wealthy communities you get
at that not by allowing them to keep
exess which is not their money you get
at that by adopting appropriate levels
of exemptions from the Statewide
property tax based on Limited in income
it's a process that we do as Zach Sheen
mentioned this morning it's a process
that's underfunded only about a million
dollars of exemption happens now that
amount can be boosted using the money
that now comes back into the education
trust fund with appropriate amendment to
19840 so it can be used there the other
thing we've heard about targeting Aid
the state does not have a good track
record of targeted Aid
programs the 24 25 million could also be
used to create a targeted aid program
outside of adequacy say to fund
Universal
preschool or to enhance literacy
programs in the state's neediest
communities so that we do have positive
experiences with targeted Aid before we
throw the baby out with the bath water
so those are the couple of points I I
wanted to make make I thank the co the
Coalition for joining our efforts to
fairly fund education today and I thank
the education committee for U being so
patient with us happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
cordelli uh thank you U for sticking
around today um
uh in in your compliments to us but I
was referring to your your comment
compliments to the Coalition and they're
wanting to get involved um and possible
um support of an income tax or sales tax
do you believe the funding um changes um
would require an income or sales tax I
think you can do it with Statewide
property tax you can do it with an
income tax you could do it with a sales
tax you could rearrange the business
taxes all of the above or just one or
two of the above so I I think there are
lots of policy Alternatives um New
Hampshire just to give us
context New Hampshire has the lowest per
capita tax level of any state in New
England we are the
lowest but
we are the most reliant on the property
tax and the property tax as we've heard
is a regressive inelastic tax that's why
people lose their homes because their
income goes down but their taxes go up
highest in the nation for funding
schools based on property
taxes actually a fairly modest tax level
of State Municipal Taxes
overall I hope that's
responsive represent beler can't see you
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony here um you mentioned the
number 24 million is what this could
stand to bring uh into the the state
funds to then be distributed out to less
wealthy districts places that need more
help but given that this is giving local
uh towns basically an ultimatum that
they're going to use these funds are
going to lose
them does that not seem rather unlikely
that they're going to choose to not
expend These funds at their local
schools and actually kick them back to
the
state um thank thank you for the
question I I I think your question to me
I I apologize for
the the machine in the way uh your
question to me representative beler and
similar to the question you asked
representative Smith uh respectfully
misunderstands what we're talking
about this isn't a question of a
discretionary spend by a local school
district the state in its wisdom has
described a formula that we've talked
about this morning 4,100 for base
adequacy 2,300 for special ed something
for kids in poverty something that
formula when you multiply it times the
number of children in attendance in or
in Residence in the school district
doing the differentiated Aid as it
applies gives you a
number let's say for Portsmith that
number is a
100 right the swept tax for Portsmith
because it has so much property wealth
maybe raises
$120 certainly Portsmith wants to spend
that 120 but it's it's not ports Smith's
money that 100 should be all they get
and the extra 20 should go to the
education trust fund for use there so if
you add up all those extra $20
income that's how you get to 24
million I hope that helps if I may just
to clarify just in case I am making some
kind of an error in my understanding of
this you're saying that this bill would
not allow local towns to spend the money
that they would be required to give that
money back to the state what I'm saying
is this bill would not allow local
communities to spend the state's
adequacy money on expenses that are not
part of
adequacy that's all I'm
saying and if they can't spend it then
the question becomes what happens to it
right right now they get to spend it on
other educational expenses that you all
don't supervise so I don't think anyone
thinks a turf football field is part of
adequacy but under the current system
that extra $20 of excess
money Tuftonboro can spend that on a
turf football field and there's nothing
you can say about it that's not the
intended purpose of of Statewide
property tax and it shouldn't be the
allowed use and it's been that way since
2011 there was a period of time when it
wasn't that way and it flipped
back and I'm happy to follow up offline
if you want but go ahead if I made one
more just real quick just because I I
want to make sure I really got this down
so given the fact that funds money going
in is money's fungible could a local
District not just say well we're going
to build that turf football field and
we're going to say it was our money from
our town portion and we're going to use
that State's portion that we would have
otherwise kicked back to the state and
we're going to take that and we're going
to call that adequacy which would then
again bring up the question of not
kicking back that money yeah so um money
is fungible but amounts are
not and so we know the formula we know
how much money each Community should
keep under the form
and if the application of the Statewide
tax in Portsmith or toonbo molten Boro
produces more than that amount it's that
extra increment that has to come back to
the state and the community should be
spending the first legitimate amount of
state tax revenue on adequacy if it
doesn't because money is fungible it
doesn't really matter the question is is
how much money are we dealing with and
in wealthy communities a dollar and a
half raises more than the cost of
adequacy in those communities that
excess is State money this bill makes it
come back to the state and corrects uh a
constitutional violation that's been
going on for 13
years are there further represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much attorney binsky for uh
your uh tremendous uh uh work in this uh
effort uh going
going with Claremont and and all the way
through and I really appreciate all of
that um all that energy effort and
professionalism um that has finally
gotten us to this point and hopefully
we're going to be at a position where
where we can uh make some moves with it
but one of the but one of the things you
you locked on to during this discussion
was the um was the low and moderate
property tax relief fund and So
currently the 25 million is dollars that
comprise the excess swept do do any of
those dollars benefit
homeowners in Newport or Charlestown or
hopkington or conquered that don't have
homes in let's say these excess swats so
so even and in particular do they bet
does do any of those excess weep dollars
benefit lowincome home homeowners in
those only very
inferentially so so follow up Mr chair M
so how would the low and moderate
Property Tax Relief Fund affect let's
say a homeowner in in Charlestown or in
hopkington yeah so the that portion of
your bill um increases or raises the
income level that makes people eligible
for exemption or relief from uh the
Statewide property tax uh it's not
different than other exemptions um we
exempt veterans we exempt lowincome
people from other taxes and it
recognizes the inelastic aspect of
property taxes and tries to correct for
that by saying if you happen to be low
income and you could be low income this
year
and not be low income next year we're
going to help you out we're not going to
put you out of your home because you
can't pay your property tax bill so it's
it's an appropriate thing right now that
24 million doesn't get used in that way
I agree that that is an appropriate use
for that money and I I'd be tickled to
see it uh deployed in that way so and
one more followup on on that cuz I I I
want to make sure and we didn't plan
this no no we didn't we didn't um but
but you mentioned the Veteran's
exemption which I believe is an o that
doesn't go away no no but which I
believe is an
overlay yes we're talking the latter
part yeah we are it's all related to
that it's in the tax section yeah um the
the veterans exemption is a local
overlay which means your other local
property tax payers are picking up the
slack on that right the low and moderate
program is completely different from
that correct it's a state it's a it's a
state exemption of a state
tax in in theory it shifts a tiny bit of
the state burden away from the lowest
earning people to everyone else so in
that way it works just like an exemption
but it's a very appropriate policy
decision
uh to make to be clear it's a very
appropriate policy decision it's not a
constitutional issue but it's a very
appropriate con uh policy decision that
I certainly uh would support okay great
thank you okay okay are there any
further
questions thank you very much uh we have
you
good afternoon again Zach Shen New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project um as I've tried to do I will um
just pull out the pieces that I think
have not been address or answer
questions to not uh reiterate a lot of
the testimony in the past um we are in
support of House Bill
1686 of all the bills we've heard today
um this is uh I think as represent Smith
pointed out this morning the most
clearcut and straightforward um if it
completely complies with the recent
rulings in the Rand lawsuit um it's a
very specific targeted fix to what has
been shown to be an
unconstitutional um deployment of the
swept um tax scheme um I think that
something that is important to focus on
is that in the Rand lawsuit also the
arguments put forward um by the state in
saying why this swept tax should not be
adjusted did not focus on the content of
the tax so much as the logistics around
changing the tax tax code arguing that
it would be hard for municipalities to
for example remit excess swept in two
months because they're already starting
to set tax rates they're already
starting to collect the tax bill to the
state focusing on the logistics of that
I believe this bill has a start date of
um 2025 that gives at this point almost
18 months for municipalities who need to
remit that excess to prepare to do that
so I don't think that would be a
specific issue um one other piece to
point out is um the conversations
relative to swept around the concerns
about folks who happen to be lower
income who happen to live in communities
that have higher property value that
might have excess swept and the argument
is often made that folks who you know
not that everyone that lives in
Portsmith is Rich that is true no one's
arguing that currently the retention of
excess swept benefits to a degree
everyone in Portsmouth regardless of
your income and relative wealth meaning
that folks who are lower income that
might have been there for 30 years are
living on a fixed income are not getting
assistance proportionate to the amount
of need they might have to their
neighbors who are making 10 times as
much as a discussion before was
happening redirecting some of that XS
swep two programs designed specifically
to provide property tax Rel for people
who need it could in fact benefit more
people with lower incomes living in
communities that have excess swept right
now
I think that I will uh leave it at that
I'll pass around my written testimony
and then one last thing is relative to
the subcommittee considering these
issues I really think it's um helpful
that this bill is also with the one that
representative Leno proposed that had
those expansions to the low and moderate
property tax relief program there could
be some creative combining of those
since this money again could be about
$25 million that could enhance that low
moderate property tax relief program um
I'll leave it at that and have happy to
take any questions are there any
questions
for none thank you very much we have one
laflame
lfam thank you again Mr chairman and
members of the committee um I'm Natalie
laflam I'm a resident of bosin and I'm
one of the attorneys on the Rand lawsuit
I promise I'm not just going to rehash
what attorney binsky said um I wanted to
talk a bit about the order and how it
fits into the ongoing litigation and
where that goes from here so as you've
heard on November 20th the court issued
an an order granting us partial summary
judgment on the swept issue so in our
case you could we split out the swept
issue from the questions about adequacy
and whether that's being appropriately
funed
which was the issue in conval as well so
we isolated swept and the judge ruled in
our favor and specifically ruled that by
administering the swept in a manner
which allows communities to retain
excess swept funds or offset the
equalized swept rate via negative local
tax rates the state has violated part
two Article 5 of the State Constitution
and it ordered both practices to stop
with the budget cycle that commences in
late 2023 and ends with budget votes in
March or April 2024
so what HB 1686 does is basically just
exactly what the court has ordered the
legislature to do order the state to
stop doing um and I just want to note
that the courts ORD is on really solid
legal ground um all courts orders are
obviously but particularly here the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has decided
these issues before nearly identical
issues it's the the law is very clear
it's a very clear violation of the state
constitution
um so basically and this might kind of
get hopefully clarify some of the
conversations that happened before but
the swept is a state tax that's meant to
fund the state's responsibility to
provide an adequate education and so
that part is key to understanding why
these questions are the argument of well
some towns are putting this money toward
their schools toward education so that's
okay no it's not because the swept is
specifically for the state's
responsibility to provide an adequate
education so the way the swept works is
it's set at a certain rate and in each
Community the swept raise there either
covers the amount the cost of adequacy
or it doesn't and when we say excess
excess communities excess literally
means it's in excess of covering
adequacy so by the state allowing those
towns to keep it even if it goes toward
their towards their schools it's going
toward non-adequate
expenses and other communities that
don't raise as much don't have that
ability and that's why it's
unconstitutional because effectively
they're not paying the same
rates so um since then the order came
out November 20th and the state and the
intervenor the Coalition communities 2.0
have asked the court to stay the order
and to reconsider the remedy and I just
really strongly urge you to still
support this bill now and not think that
you have to wait until that all plays
out um it's not actually a pending
appeal right now there's no requirement
that the decision be appealed and as of
now it has not been appealed appeals are
not automatic I think that's a common
misconception people have the state has
to affirmatively decide to appeal it
doesn't need to be reviewed by the next
court um and we would suggest here the
law is so clear the practice is no one's
debating what's actually happening here
that any decision on appeal is bound to
be the exact same thing as what the
order is we have now it's really just
delaying the inevitable and the longer
this tax goes on while the case is
pending the more taxpayers are paying
this unconstitutional tax um and it's
just a big drain on state time and
resources to keep litigating these
matters that we all know are
unconstitutional and you have an easy
fix in front of you right now um I think
it's also worth noting that when I say
this unfair tax burden it's really
shouldered by the majority of taxpayers
in the state so there were approximately
34 communities that have this excess
swept in 2021 and the Coalition I had
represented approximately 26 but I
believe I heard earlier is 27 so
thereabouts um that's less than 15% of M
municipalities in New Hampshire so 85%
are paying this effectively higher rate
because we allow this excess swept
practice to happen same thing there are
only about 22 locations with the
negative local education tax rate set um
and just a final note I just think it's
really important that we break this
mindset that the swept is redistributing
funds from one town to another that's
not what happens we talked about is a
state tax going to a state purpose the
sweat sweat funds are not sent to a town
if they're remitted to the state it goes
to the education trust fund which is
used for the state's obligation say it
with me now to fund an adequate
education um which is just benefits all
citizens of of the state and the state
itself that so that's it there's any
questions thank you represent
mil thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony I have a couple questions
first of all as you have uh as you've
monitored these kinds of cases across
the
country has there been any state that
has had a decision made in which the
state basically the legislature
basically said look
this is a problem we understand it they
just go ahead and try to solve it
without further litigation Etc are there
any states that have done that yes and
thank you for bringing that up I should
have mentioned that recently this summer
in July 2023 um the state of
Pennsylvania had a similar funding
lawsuit uh the trial court ruled in
favor of the plaintiffs so found that
the state was not adequately funding
education really long opinion like 300
Pages um and the state to its credit
just said okay we lost let's go fix it
we're not not going to bother appealing
we're just going to start fixing it so
that could that could happen here in New
Hampshire if there if the if the state
chose to they could just start fixing
the problem and not drag out the
litigation and my second question is I'm
I'm not a an attorney so could you
define the term summary judgment what
that actually means and and what the
impact of that is sure yes so summary
judgment is when an issue a case is
decided on the merits without needing to
go to a full trial so the idea is the
parties all agree on the material the
relevant important facts and it's just a
matter of law so the judge can look at
the record and apply the law and reach a
final decision so that's what happened
here with our case we like I said kind
of carved out the swept issue and
there's no debate on the tax rates the
numbers are what they are um the state
agreed so we just sent it to the court
with the looking at the law and the
facts and he granted us some re
judgement meaning we did not need to do
a full evidentiary hearing evidentiary
trial that's in contrast to the rest of
our case which we're still waiting for
trial and for conal which had to go
through you know you call witnesses and
they testify a full trial it's just
decided on the facts in the law before
it thank you any other questions
representa cordelli thank you um since
you brought up the Pennsylania case and
they resolved um the situ the funding
situation um based on the court decision
um do you know how they resolved it um
and maybe if there was additional
funding involved where they found that
additional
funding off the top of my head I'm not
sure because it just happened this
summer so I don't know if if they've
fixed it yet I think it's just more the
point I think representative Miler was
getting at was they didn't appeal so
they're they're going to start fixing it
without waiting to see if another Court
does something
different
thank you a lot of that can be found on
the education commission the state site
regarding
Pennsylvania representa
Cordell Cordell cascaden it's time to
here representative lad you need another
cup of
go yeah thank you uh for my question and
knowing that attorney Lam is the last
speaker on this bill just want to put
something in perspective if she can
answer this question question so for
years we've attempted to resolve this
school funding issue right and we
haven't gotten there and I think we are
all part of the
legislation because we want to protect
our constitutional rights am I right
it's about protecting our rights to a
fair and appropriate public
education and if we don't keep that at
the Forefront and making that happen it
could never get
resolved but in in the meantime um in
this process the the state has had to
incur uh many factors to a cost right
they've had to spend many dollars to be
able to defend themselves uh in all
these years of
lawsuits
um and really what it's done is
prevented or blocked the protection of
our constitutional rights is there any
data on how much of our money has been
spent by the state to defend themselves
to prevent this from being resolved yes
um and actually we recently did a right
to know request to the state about this
very question of how much money is being
spent on defending these lawsuits and
the response was December 22nd 2023 so I
don't have historical data of what they
spent with the 15,000 Claremont or
londondary but just conal and Rand so
conal was filed in 2019
um and the AG attorneys are handling it
but they also hired outside Council from
out of state to help defend the lawsuit
so just payments to those out of state
attorneys and this is current through
December 1st 2023 and I know they've
done things since then in the last month
but they have paid
1,848 64 27 cents just to out of state
attorneys to defend conval uh they spent
10288 And1 on other expenses things like
expert fees depositions court fees
transcripts that stuff um so that
doesn't include any calculation of how
much time from our own state attorneys
or resources has gone into this uh Rand
we filed in 2022 and again through
December 1st they have spent
349 on outof state Council fees and 20
$2,716 on other expenses so just
defending this um and of course if they
appeal that drags this out longer more
and more fees uh more money wasted
defending unconstitutional practices
from our tax revenues yes thank you so
there is not an easy
fix based upon all the money we spent in
all the years we spent addressing this
issue it's the general court doesn't
seem to move that quickly
just as a
comment so are there any further
questions this is the about ready to
close this Bild
down not see thank you very much
Natalie we'll close this hearing
and move on to tomorrow where we have
the subcommittee there's information
about the subcommittee over on the side
table
there
oh I didn't get to that I I I'll look at
yeah